[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous si vous nous rejoignez
sur le site du Figaro.fr sur la chaîne
Youtube de Figaro live nous sommes en
direct direct depuis la place du
Trocadero à Paris cet après-midi pour
vous faire vivre et bien le meeting
d'Eric
zemou bienvenue sur le site du Figaro
vous voyez les images vous venez de voir
les images en direct du
Trocadero et vous voyez qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde et c'est pour ça que
les images figent en ce moment ne vous
inquiétez pas on va les retrouver on va
retrouver l'équipe de Timothé d'lem et
de raphaë Lazreg qui est en direct donc
au Trocadero où nous nous trouvons 50000
personnes qui sont inscrites pour ce
meeting et on retrouve en ce moment les
images vous les revoyez avec nous vous
les retrouvez vous les découvrez en
direct on retrouve Timothé d Timothé on
vous laisse la
parole alors Timothé va reprendre la
parole dans quelques minutes voyez donc
les images en direct qui nous reviennent
du du Trocadero qui nous remontent du
Trocadero par l'Agence France Presse qui
est également en direct sur ce site on
aura également les discours de euh du
candidat cet après-midi prévu aux
alentours de 16h et également une
dizaine de personnes qui sont prévu
juste auparavant donc pour pour parler
juste auparavant pH et Marion maréchal
et puis avant eux une dizaine de
personnes on est vous le voyez en
plateau en studio avec quelqu'un que
vous connaissez si vous avez suivi les
précédents
meetings vous connaissez sans doute
Guillaume Bernard on va corriger on a
fait une petite erreur sur le bordeau et
on va corriger on va on va mettre le bon
orthographe à trocado on va demander à
Riad en régie de le faire Guillaume
bonjour vous êtes politologue on le
rappelle maître de conférence de less à
la rocheurion et auteur de cet ouvrage
absolument essentiel pour comprendre euh
le les débats à
droite cet ouvrage qui s'appelle la
guerre à droite aura bien lieu je vous
pose une question en attendant puisque
je vois que on a repris retrouvé la
liaison avec Timothé d'EM une première
question pour vous quel est l'enjeu de
cet après-midi pour Éric Zemour il a une
démonstration de force telle manière que
cela puisse
enrayer la tendance baissière comme on
dit dans les sondages euh qu'il connaît
depuis quelques semaines donc stopper
cette baisse et d'une certaine manière
donner un coup comme au fond de la
piscine et remonter c'est en tout cas ce
qu'il espère obtenir de cette
démonstration de force utiliser le
symbole évidemment je dirais du du
meeting au Trocadero où François Fillon
il y a 5 ans avait maintenu sa
candidature il y avait terminé malgré
toutes les affaires qu' l'entouraient et
bien à près de enfin un peu plus de 19 %
donc un score qui était très loin d'être
assuré donc par conséquent effectivement
Éric Zemour là joue son vatou il veut
essayer d'atteindre le second tour il en
est très loin pour l'instant mais en
faisant de belles images en montrant une
foule en liè en montrant que il est
capable de mobiliser un très grand
nombre de militants et ça des militants
il est incontestable qu'il en a et bien
il peut espérer ou il espère en tout cas
et bien euh avoir une image meilleure et
repartir à la hausse dans les sondages
alors on va revoir comment on peut
repartir à la hausse dans les dans les
sondages euh vigou nous dit c'est faux
les sondages sont bidons vigou il nous
rejoint sur la chaîne Youtube et on
salue tous les internautes qui nous
retrouvent sur la chaîne Youtube alors
que je vois Timothée et John teamsit qui
sont sur un peu à côté de la place du
Trocadero on va aller les les les
retrouver juste une question est-ce que
les sondages sont faux non ils ne sont
pas faux ils peuvent se tromper parce
que effectivement par exemple pour Éric
Zemour il y a une difficulté à à je
dirais estimer son résultat réel puisque
les sondages donnent des résultats bruts
et les Institutes de sondage les
redresse il les redressent grâce à quoi
grâce aux études qu'ils font auparavant
et au résultats réels des élections donc
quelqu'un qui est un nouveau candidat
qui n'est pas euh comment dire qui n'a
pas déjà été testé c'est plus difficile
de le tester que d'autres mais pour
autant les institut de sondage ne
cherchent pas à mentir ça irait
totalement contre leurs intérêts c'est
intéressant justement d'avoir
cette ce point de vue d'un politologue
qui nous explique que c'est difficile de
noter un déévaluer un candidat qui ne
s'est jamais présenté d'ailleurs on
avait fait on avait sous-évalué par
exemple Emmanuel Macron lors de la
précédente élection présidentielle en ne
prévoyant pas qu' finirait premier
absolument on va retrouver Timothé qui
est avec nous Timothé est-ce que vous
m'entendez
[Musique]
oui Vincent je vous entends très bien je
vous le disais juste avant que nous
soyons coupés il y a beaucoup de monde
sur cette place du Trocadero cet
après-midi he 50000 personnes sont
attendu d'après les équipes d'Er Zemour
et c'est la raison pour laquelle et bien
forcément au niveau du réseau on a du
mal à à capter vous l'avez vu sur ces
images tout à l'heure de Raphaël lazrec
beaucoup de drapeau beaucoup de de monde
donc sur cette place du du Trocadero ce
sont les aléas du du direct pour
l'instant le meeting n'a pas encore à
proprement parler débuté en tout cas les
interventions à la tribune n'ont pas
encore débuté on a vu et bien plusieurs
clips de campagne qui ont été qui sont
qui ont été diffusés sur les h écrans
géants déployés pour pour l'occasion la
la la place pour l'instant est en train
d'être chauffée à blanc il y a eu
également un quiz qui a été qui a été
qui a pardon été diffusé pour pour les
les participants avec des questions
question de type combien de d'immigrés y
a-t-il eu de plus en France sous le
quinquenat d'Emmanuel Macron voilà
beaucoup de de musique beaucoup de quiz
beaucoup d'interaction également il y a
des membres de l'équipe de
l'organisation de campagne d'éc Zemour
qui sont passés à la tribune et qui ont
donc alpagué un petit peu les les les
foules pour l'instant les interventions
des officiels n'ont pas encore débuté
toute la la garde rapprochée d'Éric
Zemour est présente cette après-midi
bien entendu nous avons aperçu en ce qui
nous concerne Gilbert card nous avons
aperçu également Jean Messia nous avons
aperçu le le jeune porte-parole du parti
reconquête également Stanislas Rigot
voilà beaucoup de monde en tout cas cet
après-midi nous en ce qui nous concerne
nous sommes avec John Timsit journaliste
politique au Figaro John pour une petite
analyse sur ce meeting euh déjà
John beaucoup de de commentateurs
parlent un petit peu du meeting de la
dernière chance pour Erric Zemour
Vincent roule disait à l'instant avec
avec Guillaume Bernard en plateau Éric
Zemour pour l'instant c'est c'est à peu
près 11 % au niveau des des sondages
quelle est votre analyse bah c'est vrai
que depuis le début de l'offensive russe
en Ukraine la campagne d Zemour s
totalement enrayée il est
passé d'un niveau autour de 15 16 %
tutoyant la 2e place à un niveau
aujourd'hui autour de comme vous l'avez
dit de 10 11
% où il rivalise avec Valéri pcrè pour
savoir qui aura la 4e ou la 5e place
donc c'est vrai qu'en un mois Eric
Zemour a connu une chute euh et Éric
Zemour et son équipe misent beaucoup sur
ce meeting voilà sur ces images
impressionnantes cette foule ces
drapeaux français ce beau temps aussi ça
compte pour remobiliser les troupes et
pour
essayer de d'à nouveau d'enclencher une
dynamique dans dans l'opinion d'en crrer
un nouveau récit parce que il reste de
semaines il reste très peu de temps et
donc c'est vraiment là le moment où la
cristallisation fait de l'opinion se
fait fa bah chez les Français donc Eric
Zemour va abattre l'une de ces dernières
cartes et c'est bah celle du Trocadero
justement cette carte du Trocadero c'est
une forte symbolique ce lieu n'a pas été
choisi au hasard on se souvient bien
entendu des images et bien de ce
meeting Nicolas Sarkozi c'était le 1er
mai 2012 lors de l'entre de tour avec
François Hollande sous un grand soleil
également il y avait eu ce meeting de
François Fillon cette fois-ci pleuait
c'était en 2017 alors qu'il était englué
dans les campagnes il avait pu
rassembler ses soutiens au Trocadero ERC
Zemour c'est pas un choix un choix au
hasard cet après-midi le 3 C non c'est
un clin d'œil assumé comme comme vous
l'avez dit à la campagne de Nicolas
Sarkozi en 2012 puis à celle de de
François Fillon à chaque fois dans des
contextes assez différents Nicolas
Sarkozi on est le premier ma 2012 les
sondages se resserent vraiment avec
François Hollande et ce meeting en tout
cas s'il lui permet pas de gagner à la
fin lu lui permet encore plus et de
resserer l'écart et d'atteindre les
48 36 % à la fin et pour François Fillon
on s'en souvient c'est un meeting très
particulier dans avec le poids pesant
des affaires et donc François Fillon
avait essayé de de aussif et de relancer
sa campagne bon avec le résultat qu'on
connaît à la fin sur le fond qu'est-ce
que cela veut dire à qui est-ce que Eric
Zemour va chercher à s'adresser cet
après-midi est-ce qu'il va aller
chercher les déçus des républicains
est-ce qu'il va aller chercher plutôt
des électeurs au rassemblement
nationalah c'est assez difficile à dire
il est vrai que le choix du Trocadero
est un clin d'œil comme je l'ai dit
assumé au aux électeurs des républicains
mais le problème c'est que ces électeurs
fionistes aujourd'hui ne sont plus
encore unis et ils sont séparés certains
sont partis chez Macron certains sont
chez chez Marine Le Pen et certains sont
chez lui doncour va tenter oui fait de
parler à cette ctorat à ce bloc
siioniste de 2017 pour essayer de de les
ramener à lui et d'essayer de de réduire
l'écart qui s'est creusé ces dernières
semaines surtout entre Marine Le Pen et
lui vous avez suivi cette campagne de
remour vous la suivez pour le pour Le
Figaro depuis plusieurs mois est-ce que
vous avez eu des indiscrétions peut-être
des des off comme on dit dans le milieu
sur et bien la teneur du discours d'éc
Zemmour cet après-midi alors pas
particulièrement mais ce qu'on nous dit
c'estemour va revenir aux origines de sa
candidature pourquoi est-ce qu'il s'est
présenté pourquoi est-ce qu'il a fait ce
choix de passer de polémiste écrivain à
succès à
candidat officiel à la à la à la
fonction suprême donc réponse dans 1
heure et dem je pense mais je pense que
ce sera un discours assez large qui
voilà qui qui embrassera un petit peu le
le récit de cette campagne et et de
cette candidature merci beaucoup John
journaliste politique au Figaro pour
cette pour cette analyse alors que
Vincent vous le voyez peut-être sur les
images les images fournies par le
candidat Raphaël lazrec du Figaro essaie
de vous le montrer à l'instant c'est
Stanislas Rigo le jeune porte-parole du
parti reconquête qui est en train de
prendre la parole à la tribune alors que
les les militants eux sont en train de
de de scander Zemour président avec leur
drapeau bleu blanc rouge qui ont été qui
leur ont été distribués àors rentrer sur
la place du Trocadero cet après-midi
oui merci beaucoup Timothé effectivement
pendant que vous parliez on a diffusé
ces images effectivement les images
fournies par l'équipe de campagne du
candidat Éric Zemour merci à John
teamsit d'avoir répondu à ces premières
questions vizman Milou Paul bris Dango
nous rejoignne merci beaucoup de nous
rejoindre sur le site du Figaro on va
reprendre vos commentaires
merci de respecter les chartes de
modération et euh les opinions des uns
et des autres sont les bienvenus mais
dans le cadre justement de la charte de
modération du Figaro qui refuse bien
entendu tout ce qui est interdit par les
lois et qui refuse également tout ce qui
est de l'ordre de l'insulte ou de la
calomnie donc euh au-delà de ça et bien
tous les points de vue sont acceptés
seront donnés seront lu en fonction de
leur arrivée du rythme de leur arrivée
vous êtes très nombreux également à nous
suivre sur la chaîne Youtube de Figaro
live merci beaucoup et euh on a
également pas mal de de débats de
réponse aux questions que vous posiez
justement où est Éric Zemour dans les
sondages et ben John vient de nous le
dire à l'instant aux alentours de 11
% Django nous disait tout à l'heure
Guillaume que le
Trocadero c'est quand il appelle ça la
droite des losers euh
John le disait à l'instant Nicolas
Sarkozi fait le meeting du 1er mai 2012
troca François Fillon fait le meeting de
5 mars 2017 au Trocadero dans les deux
cas ils ont perdu oui c'est parfaitement
exact et dansentourage de Marine Le Pen
aujourd'hui on dit jamais
203 bon écoutez ça on verra bien moi je
n'ai pas de boule de cristal c'est exact
mais il ne faut pas oublier une chose
c'est que le choix à été fait
vraisemblablement tout simplement pour
rassembler un camp c'est-à-dire que
Zemour fait au premier tour une campagne
de premier tour alors elle peut déplaire
effectivement à un certain nombre de
personnes et à l'évidence il y a un
certain nombre de d'électeurs qui
étaaient susceptible d'aller vers lui
qui s'en sont finalement détournés
puisqu'il a baissé dans les sondages
mais l'idée du Trocadero en tout cas moi
je n'ai pas
d'éléments comment dire donné en off
mais l'analyse que j'en fais c'est de
choisir un lieu qui parle à cet
électorat qui est un électorat de droite
qui s'assume donc
qui dont la campagne de 2007 de Sarkozi
avait plus dont la campagne de 2012
aussi avait plus il a finalement perdu
on le sait bien en 2012 parce que sans
doute les promesses qu'il avait faites
en 2007 il ne les avait pas
véritablement tenu mais en tout cas le
choix du Trocadero c'est
euh me semble-t-il un choix pour envoyer
un message subliminal d'unité n'est-ce
pas de ce corps électoral et j'aurais
plutôt tendance à dire que pour le coup
c'est moins l'électorat de Marine Le Pen
que celui de Valérie pcrè l'électorat
résiduel de de Valérie pcrè qu'il
cherche à séduire cet après-midi alors
cela dit c'est vrai les deux derniers
meetings de la droite au Trocadero ont
finalement abouti à une défaite mais là
de toute façon on n'est même pas au
deuxème tour est-ce qu'ils ont est-ce
qu'ils ont abouti à une défaite ou plus
exactement est-ce que malgré ces
meetings au Trocadero il y a eu des
défaites oui malgré c'est plutôt ça vous
avez raison c'est malgré cela il y a eu
une défaite mais elles ont été moins
cuisantes qu'elles n'auraiit pu l'être
si effectivement il n'y avait pas eu un
sursaut de mobilisation cela dit c'est
vrai que moi je m'attendais plutôt s'il
devait y avoir un meeting parisien fait
par Éric Zemour je m'attendais plutôt à
ce qu'il aille sur la place vaauan un
peu plus petite c'est vrai mais enfin il
y a beaucoup d'avenu tout autour tout
simplement parce qu'il aurait pu avoir
les Invalides derrière lui et la
chapelle dans laquelle il y a le tombeau
de Napoléon l'unité Louis XIV Napoléon
comme symbole politique pour ce qu'il
essaye de construire idéologiquement
parlant ça m'aurait paru plus cohérent
que la tour effffel mais encore une fois
il y a je dirais des symboles qui sont
plus forts il y a des comment dire des
des des des approches qui paraissent je
dirais plus connu de tout et qui parle
un plus grand nombre essayer de limiter
la casse et essayer de rassembler son
camp il me semble que c'est ça la
stratégie et d'éc Zemour je suis pas
certain que son équipe croit encore à la
possibilité d'atteindre le deuxème tour
mais en revanche d'essayer de monter le
plus haut possible ça sans aucun doute
ils essayent de le de l'envisager alors
il y a-t-il beaucoup de monde par
rapport à ce qui était attendu c'est ce
que nous dit Thomas autre question où
ils sont où les 50000 autre remarque
c'est toujours impressionnant les marées
humaines alors la vérité c'est que à
l'heure où on se parle le seul chiffre
la seule évaluation de ce public dont on
dispose c'est le nombre de personnes qui
se sont inscrites sur le site d'Eric
Zemour il y en a un peu plus de 50000 on
annonce même dans certains médias que
60000 personnes sont attendues en
fonction justement de ce paramètre là la
question est de savoir Guillaume si les
50000 personnes qui sont inscrites
seront là ou non l'autre enjeu qu'il y a
euh et donc je vous invite à regarder
les images qui nous sont euh alors là
effectivement fourni par l'équipe de
campagne dès que Timothé qui est en
train de rechercher des personnes pour
les interroger sera en mesure de nous le
dire on lui posera la question bien bien
évidemment mais en tous les cas ce que
l'on voit déjà c'est que le parterre qui
sépare la place proprement dite le
parvis des Droits de l'Homme sur lequel
se trouve la scène et où prendra ERC
Zemour prendra la parole et le premier
terrepin du Trocadero cet espace là lui
il est rempli
oui alors c'est une place qui fait
paraît-il je me suis renseigné je ne
suis pas allé mesurer 21000 m car euh
autrement dit si on estime qu'il y a
environ 3o personnes par mètre carré bon
on peut en mettre six évidemment mais
alors dans ce cas-là on est dans les
transports en commun agglutinés aux
heures de pointe bon mais si on pense
qu'il y a environ trois personnes par
mètre carré la place contient environ
60000 personnes et donc on SAA à peu
près je dirais s'il a réussi à faire
aussi bien que les chiffres réels
évidemment de François Fillon il y a il
y a 5 ans puisque naturellement
évidemment il y a toujours les chiffres
organisateurs les chiffres police les
chiffres organisateurs sont très souvent
gonflés les chiffres polices sont très
souvent minorés on peut donner à peu
près comme règle au téléspectateurs le
fait queon additionne la les chiffres
police et le chiffre et les chiffres
organisateurs et on divise cette somme
par deux pour avoir le chiffre à peu
près réel mais c'est sûr que quand euh
les républicains avaient annoncé 200000
personnes il y a 5 ans c'était
évidemment même s'il y avait du monde
dans les avenues adjacentes c'était
évidemment parfaitement exagéré euh la
euh place peut donc contenir grosso modo
60000 personnes euh je dirais que si
déjà la place est remplie ce serait un
chiffre réel de 60000 personnes encore
une foisin les organisateurs annoncent
toujours beaucoup plus mais un chiffre
réel de 60000 personnes ce serait déjà
effectivement un très très très gros
meeting et puis s'il y a du monde dans
les avenu adjacentes et bien peut-être
qu'il atteindra le chiffre symbolique
des 100000 euh il est clair que euh il y
a toujours une difficulté à faire un
meeting à Paris parce que ça oblige les
provinciaux à monter ça représente un
coup euh les militants sont fatigués
parce que ça fait déjà des semaines
qu'il qu'ils font qu'ils font la
campagne et puis ça donne un peu le
signe de allez la province doit écouter
ce que lui dit Paris et ça c'est pas
toujours très bon je dirais que c'est
peut-être là la principale différence de
type de campagne entre Eric Zemmour et
Marine Le Pen Marine Le Pen est allé en
province faire des petits meetings des
petites salles est aller à la rencontre
des gens d'une certaine manière pour les
écouter tandis qu'Éric Zemour fait des
grosses salles des gros meetings et ça
peut apparaître auprès d'une partie de
l'électorat comme étant la grosse
machine parisienne qui soit appelle les
gens à monter à Paris c'est le cas du
Trocadero soit se déplace en province
pour porter la bonne parole voilà il il
y a deux deux styles mais c'est vrai que
ça correspond à peut-être à deux
sociologies ou à deux types d'électorat
un petit peu différents alors on a vu
tout à l'heure on voit en ce moment la
l'ancienne eurodéputée rassemblement
national maxette pierbacas prendre la
parole devant les personnes rassemblé
les milliers de personnes les dizaines
de milliers de personnes on peut dire
rassemblé de donc place du Trocadero où
on retrouve à on va retrouver Timothé
dellem mais là ça fige un peu donc que
on va attendre un petit peu que l'image
redevient un peu fluide peut-être qu'on
va écouter en en attendant la personne
qui justement est en train de s'exprimer
devant les militants il a été éuré
onécoute j'er l'abandon de nos
territoires par la puissance publique
l'état
défaillant des petites les petites
Baronnies
territoriales redistribuant les rentes à
le seul centè
[Musique]
électorale avec éic nous avons conçu un
projet présidentiel réaliste pour les
outrenires ce que j'ai senti en Eric
c'est une vraie implication pour faire
avancer nos dossiers et pour considérer
les 2,8 millions d'habitants des
outremes comme des Français à part
entière nous ne voulons pas être une
belle image et une carte postale nous
les
outrèes mais nous ce que nous voulons
c'est que nos territoires soit traité
avec équité et respect et c'est avec toi
Éric que nous aurons cette équité et ce
respecticés c'est n Président c'est n
Président c'est n président
oui Eric oui Eric j'ai confiance en toi
tu n'es pas de ces marchands de rêve qui
viennent dans nos territoires la bouche
pleine de
promesses et tout ça pour juste faire de
l'image avec de colliers de fleurs
autour du
cou ERC tu seras un grand président de
la République pour les
outrenires
et je crois que nos compatriotes
ultrmarins commencent à s'en apercevoir
aujourd'hui mes amis mes compatriotes
ultrarins il nous r désormais qu' jours
pour nous battre sur le terrain qu'
jours pour convaincre qu' jours pour
gagner est-ce que vous allez tout donner
pour que ça arrive ou
nous allons
[Applaudissements]
gagner comme je dis en le 10 avril
nous
pour VI la République vive la France
et
Marse voilà on vient d'entendre donc
maxette pierrebacas donc ancienne
élu rassemblement national alors que
l'ancien sénateur rassemblement national
également et ancien maire du 13e secteur
de Marseille Stéphane Ravier est en
train de prendre la parole peut-être un
un commentaire avant d'écouter Stéphane
Ravier Guillaume euh sur ce que l'on
vient d'entendre
euh très clairement il y avait une cible
subliminale dans ce discours c'est clair
euh le fait de faire parler une élu
venant des Antilles c'était pour essayer
de répondre à la présence de Marine Le
Pen en Guadeloupe euh évidemment pour
essayer je dirais de de contrebalancer
l'influence qu'elle peut essayer
d'obtenir en étant là-bas simplement
voilà je reprends un peu l'idée que j'
vais évoqué tout à l'heure un candidat
qui se déplace pour aller voir les gens
et pour les écouter c'est souvent plus
efficace que simplement tenir un
discours depuis Paris voilà et de ce
point de vue-là effectivement Marine Le
Pen a une présence et a reçu semble-t-il
un accueil au moins d'une partie de la
population assez assez favorable Marine
Le Pen qui se trouve en Guadeloupe
d'ailleurs en ce moment on va écouter
euh Stéphane Ravier et ensuite on
essaiera de reprendre Timothé d'è sur
place de tout un
peuple la France la France aura le
dernier mot contre tous ceux qui veulent
la
détruire avec le Z avec le Z nous allons
enfin reprendre notre droit de vivre
dans une
France nous allons notre droit de vivre
dans une France française le droit de
transmettre à nos enfants ce que nous
ont transmis nos parents le droit d'être
à nouveau fier d'être
français quant à ceux qui préfèrent une
France
islamisée ceux qui sont venus d'ailleurs
pour dénaturer notre pays ils pourront
aussi faire le voyage dans l'autre
sens
avec Emmanuel Macron les frontières
étaient ouvertes pour entrer avec éc
Zemour les frontières seront toujours
ouvertes mais pour
sortir
face face au grand remplacement qui
inquiète 63 % des Français et que seul
Marine Le Pen ne voit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas
le ministère de la
rémigration le ministère de la
rmigration voilà on va écouter continuer
à écouter Stéphane Ravier on vous
raconte juste après on va retrouver B
justement au sein de la place du
Trocadero Timothé d'lem Timothé une
première peut-être question avant que
vous interrogiez le militant qui se
trouve à côté de vous est-ce qu'il y a
du
monde
[Musique]
oui Vincent il y a il y a beaucoup de
monde ici au Trocadero c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a tant de mal à avoir
une bonne une bonne connexion nous
étions tout à l'heure et bien vraiment
au milieu de la place tout au milieu de
la place et là il y avait vraiment une
foule très condensée avec donc une
militante effectivement on
voit effectivement on voit qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde parce que là encore
une fois çaffige alors pourquoi çaffige
et bien parce que il y a beaucoup de
monde et beaucoup de monde concentré
dans un dans un périmètre donné c'est ce
qui nous arrive souvent lorsque on on
retransmet les cérémonies du 14 juillet
c'est toujours un cetê pour les équipes
de Figaro live et on retrouve on
retrouve Timothé DLEM donc on va le
réécouter on a eu Timothé qui avait du
monde voilà je sais pas si vous
m'entendez Vincent c'est vrai que il y a
beaucoup de monde beaucoup d'allé à
technique cet après-midi là nous sommes
et bien bien dans la deuxième partie de
la place du trogadero si je pu
m'exprimer ainsi je sais pas si vous
arrivez à nous situer donc la foule est
un petit peu moins condensée ici comme
vous le voyez sur ces images et bien de
notre journaliste reporteur d'imagees
Raphaël lazre qui est en train de vous
montrer la foule alors que les
interventions à la tribune se
poursuivent Stéphane Ravier a terminé
son intervention c'est maintenant
Laurence Trochu la présidente du
mouvement conservateur qui est en train
de prendre la parole alors nous allons
interroger un militant juste avance
l'avancant une petite information sur
les inter les intervenants à la à la
tribune c'est toujours assez compliqué
lors des meetings d'Éric zéour de savoir
en
avance la phrase de Timothé c'est que il
est toujours difficile de savoir à la
fin ah voilà on entend Timothé on
l'entend
plus alors on va écouter Laurence Trochu
le temps de retrouver de l'age alors je
sais pas si vous m'entendez VC je crois
ents
bienance voilà je disais à l'instant
donc que les interventions à la tribune
sont très condensés on nous disait tout
à l'heure du côté de l'organisation et
bien qu'il y aurait une dizaine
d'intervention mais plus qu' ENIT que
que les dernières lors des derniers
meetings donc
davantage on va on va faire une pause on
va attendre que la laillante et
l'imageevine écter Laurence nos enfants
car ils sont la France de
demain chè famille française vous êtes
venus nombreus soutenir Éric Zemour et
je suis heureuse de vous voir et de vous
[Musique]
entendre avec éc Zemour nous avons une
conviction
forte les familles sont le cœur battant
de la
France tant qu'on ne consolidera pas la
famille nous ne pourrons espérer une
société plus juste plus sûre où chacun
trouve sa place vive en sécurité et
puisse développer ses
talents alors alors chers amis à ceux
qui au nom du progressisme ont
déconstruit la
famille en affirmant qu'un père ça
peut-être une grand-mère
à ceux qui ont trahi la politique
familiale en la réduisant à une
politique
sociale à ceux qui se sont imissés dans
nos vies au point de régentter
l'organisation du congé
parental à ceux qui soumettent l'humain
à la logique des marchés de sa
fabrication à
l'euthanasie à cela à celui-là qui fuit
les débat pour ne pas être comptable de
son sinistre
bilan nous rappelons que l'histoire que
l'histoire ne s'écrit pas à partir d'une
page
blanche
l'histoire chers amis nous l'écrivons
avec nos vies fê de joie d'épreuves
aussi et d'espérance
surtout voilà pourquoi notre engagement
pour la famille est le point de départ
de la société que nous voulons durable
parce que prendre soin de la famille
c'est prendre soin de la société tout
entière c'est un
combat c'est un combat pour la
solidarité pour l'éducation pour la
transmission pour la prospérité et pour
la paix c'est un combat pour la
vie et nous et nous femmes de tous âges
nous le savons bien nous sommes en
première ligne face au mots que traverse
la France d'un côté 40 ans d'immigration
et d'augmentation de
l'insécurité nous menace au
quotidien de l'autre de l'autre un
féminisme agressif nous m en compétition
avec
l'homme et nous soumet à une pression
constante souvent non choisie entre vie
professionnelle et vie familiale il est
grand temps de nous libérer de ce
féminisme qui a
[Applaudissements]
réduit qui a réduit la féminité et la
masculinité à des constructions sociales
ce féminisme qui émascule les hommes et
travestit les
femmes alors oui
respectter respecter protéger les femmes
c'est aussi reconnaître et valoriser ce
que nous
d'unique le fait de porter la vie et
d'avoir avec l'enfant un lien charnel
qu'aucune idéologie ne peut abolir n'en
déplaise à Simone de
[Applaudissements]
Beauvoir que les féministes continuent
ainsi à maltraiter la féminité en la
caricaturant et nous verrons
naturellement se lever en politique des
femmes qui ne veulent d' société où la
lutte des classes se transforme en lutte
des
sexes français nous sommes les héritiers
d'une civilisation qui vit les liens
entre hommes et femmes sur le mode de la
[Applaudissements]
complémentaritéette vision défend er
Zemour pour que les femmes françaises
puissent révéler leurs talent et vivre
sereinement français nous sommes les
héritiers d'une civilisation que nous
aimons que nous voulons protéger et
qu'il nous revient de transmettre alors
si aujourd'hui un avenir est possible
pour la France et les Français c'est
parce qu'un homme s'est levé et
s'élève
il s'élève contre les saboteurs de la
France ceux qui liqufi ses repères et
liquide son héritage mais rien ne se
fera sans vous sans chacun de
[Applaudissements]
vous chers amis il ne s'agit plus d'un
vote utile il s'agit d'un vote vital il
est entre vos mains et avec vous
impossible n'est pas
[Applaudissements]
français on retrouve retourne dans les
studio du Figaro et avec Guillaume
Bernard qui est avec nous on vient
d'entendre Laurence Trochu Laurence
strochu c'est le mouvement conservateur
donc anci sens commun ancien sens commun
donc c'est la tendance c'est la partie
manif pour tous absolument alors tout le
mouvement de la manif pour tous n'est
pas pour Éric Zemour naturellement il y
a une partie de ceux-l qui ont manifesté
contre la loi tobira qui ont et vont
voter pour le rassemblement national
mais il est bien évident qu'il y a une
très grande partie de lmpt qui se
retrouve dans sens commun maintenant
dans le mouvement conservateur et donc
effectivement dans le vote pour Éric
Zemour maintenant le mouvement
conservateur qui faisait partie
d'ailleurs enfin qui était un mouvement
qui était lié au républicains jusqu'à
jusque
un parti associé comme républicain on va
retrouver donc Timothé dem et là c'est
Benjamin Cochi ancienne figure des DLR
et des gilets jaunes qui est en train de
prendre la parole on va quand même
retrouver
Timothé Timothé là on vous voit mieux on
vous voit plus
clair et vous avez dû encore
reculer voilà exactement Vincent nous
avons d encore reculé euh pour des
questions de de réseau nous étions tout
à l'heure au centre de la place du
Trocadero nous sommes maintenant dans
une avenue adjacente euh qui arrive sur
cette place donc il y a moins de monde à
priori on capte mieux comme vous le
voyez sur ces images de Raphaël Lazreg
qui va vous montrer des militants qui
continuent euh de d'arriver place du
Trocadero il y a encore beaucoup de
monde he qui arrive c'est un flux
continu avec donc euh cette fouille
obligatoire plusieurs agents de de
sécurité
les interventions à la tribune qui se
poursuivent c'est maintenant
benjaminochi une ancienne figure des
gilets jaunes qui est en train de
prendre la parole moi je suis avec un un
militant qui a eu la patience de nous
attendre merci vous êtes et bien
adhérant à génération Z le mouvement de
de jeunes de soutien à Eric Zemour
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes venu cet
après-midi au Trocadero alors
principalement moi je veux souligner le
fait que je suis pas Français j'ai pas
la nationalité française et j'habite en
France depuis 17 ans et ericour c'est le
seul candidat qui vraiment m'a donné
envie de non seulement d'être français
mais vraiment de Me de d'avoir la
nationalité j'ai vécu d'abord à montre
et puis à sainttoin donc toutes les
situations que Zemour décrit donc tous
les problèmes d'immigration moi je les
vis tous les jours et malheureusement
c'est une réalité qui est niée par
nombreuses personnes Eton ce qui me
plaît c'est que il parle vraiment en
français et il aime la France et il aime
les Français et il veut que la France
reste la France depuis quand est-ce que
vous avvez choisi de soutenir éc Zemour
alors ça va faire 2 mois avant qu' qu'il
annonce sa candidature et donc vous avez
assisté déjà je crois vous me disiez
tout à l'heure au myic de de de
Villepinte qu'est-ce qui vous frappe
dans la campagne de derric Zemour alors
qu'est-ce qui me frappe c'est c'est
l'honnêteté tout d'abord et l'engouement
qu'il y a dans les meetings c'est c'est
exceptionnel il faut juste si on se
tourne ici c'est les gens sont sont
exaltés sont contents et ça transpire le
la joie et le bonheur pour l'instant éc
Zemour se trouve à peu près autour de 11
% dans les dans les sondages il n'est
pas qualifié au second tour il est même
en train de il est au cou à coude en
fait avec Valérie P la candidate des
républicains ça se joue entre la 4 et la
5e place 5e place pour lui est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il a ses chances
d'accéder malgré tout au second tour
dans de semaines alors c'est vrai que
c'est c'est c'est pas simple de voir ses
numéros sur les sondages mais on sait
très bien que la très grande partie des
Français sont encore indécis donc
croisons les doigts et on verra le
résultat quoi juste avec l'engouement
qu'il y a dans les meetings c'est sûr
que 10 % ça représente pas vraiment ce
que toutes les personnes qui vont voter
zour sur le fond qu'est-ce que vous
attendez du discours d' zour cet
après-midi alors sur le fond
principalement moi je connais
pratiquement toutes ceses propositions
donc je suis venu aussi pour une
curiosité et juste pour voir les
personnes le contentement dans dans
visage
personne juste une bonne ambiance quoi
donc voilà merci beaucoup voilà V nous
étions donc avec un militant on vous
laisse et bien accéder à cette fouille
avec les services de sécurité pour
pouvoir rentrer sur la place du
Trocadero merci beaucoup voilà Vincent
donc pour cette cette interview de ce
militant et les interventions qui se
poursuivent à la tribune avec Benjamin
Kochi qui vient tout juste de terminer
son intervention et vous voyez donc sur
images rap lazre qui vous montre la
fouille des des militants
justé voilà avec beaucoup d'agents de
sécurité vous les voyez pas tous à
l'image oui alors justement la question
qui est posée d'ailleurs par Terry c'est
comment se passe justement l'accès
est-ce qu'on est fouillé est-ce que
comment se passe le le le contrôle et
comment on on garantit qu'il n'y a pas
de euh d'affrontement de de problèm
puisqu'il y a un petit il y a un enjeu
quand même autour de cette question
c'était en cas ce qu'on pouvait dire ces
derniers jours se à PIR trouver une
[Musique]
solution oui tout à fait c'est un c'est
un enjeu d'ailleurs euh ce que ce que
l'on sait ce qui nous a été dit par les
par les équipes du candidat c'est que
8000 personnes force de sécurité
seraient 800 pardon agents de sécurité
propre à Eric Zemour serait du service
d'or d'éc Zemour serait déployé cet
après-midi en plus des 8 force de
l'ordre et là on voit effectivement un
dispositif très important avec comme
vous le voyez vous l'avez vu à l'instant
et Raphaël va vous le remontrer à
nouveau beaucoup de personnel chaque
personne est fouillée ça a été notre cas
pour nous les journalistes nous avons
été fouillés obligatoirement avant de
pénétrer sur la place du Trocadero et
comme vous le voyez sur ces images et
bien toutes les personnes sont fouillées
les sacs également sont sont fouiller
attentivement et et pour tout vous dire
nous nous allons devoir nous déplacer
dans quelques
parce que précisément pour des raisons
de sécurité les AG sont en train de nous
demander de nous déplacer voilà mais en
tous les cas la fouille est assez
stricte ici aux abords de la place du
Trocadero alors on va rester avec vous
gars
laisser vos images parce que pour
l'instant ce sont les seuls dont on
dispose il semble que il y a en ce
moment des clips qui sont diffusés
d'ailleurs sur le compte Youtube
de officiel d' Zemour où il y a quand
même énormément de de monde 50000
personnes sur le sur le sur la page
Youtube du d'éc Zemour vous êtes un peu
plus de 5000 à nous suivre actuellement
sur notre page Youtube vous êtes
également très nombreux à nous suivre
sur la le chat et la home du Figaro on
sent que le débat est vif que tout le
monde n'est pas d'accord je rappelle
condition déjà se respecter et ne pas
calomier euh les euh uns ou les autres
et bien entendu de respecter également
le média sur lequel vous vous trouvez
euh sinon on n'hésitera pas un à modérer
et de s'il le faut abanir euh deuxème
une question quand même par rapport à ce
qui se dit est ce que l'on entend est ce
que l'on peut voir euh Guillaume euh
c'est que en tous les cas une un des
internautes visem le disait tout à
l'heure on comparait par rapport à à
François Fillon il y a 5 ans ce qui est
vrai c'est que là où incontestablement
Zemour réussit son Paris aujourd'hui
c'est que lui il part de rien à
l'origine ah mais bien sûr Éric Zemour
c'est la révélation de la campagne 2022
il faut bien dire cette campagne est pas
toujours aussi enthousiasmante qu' on
aurait pu l'espérer mais il est
incontestable quel que soit le sentiment
que l'on a vis-à-vis d'Héric Zemour que
son émergence sa transformation de
journaliste en candidat qui n'était
absolument pas évidente sa capacité à
prendre la parole devant une foule
immense à parler certes avec des
prompteurs mais enfin à parler de
manière assez assez libre et non pas je
dirais courbé sur son pupitre ça n'était
absolument pas gagné or c'est la
révélation de la campagne d'autre part
réussir à engranger je ne sais pas si
les chiffres sont parfaitement exacts
mais au moins 100000 adhérents en
quelques mois c'est incontestablement
une réussite alors elle s'explique cette
réussite par le fait que il y avait un
appel d'air qu'il y avait un vide que il
y a eu des années de travail de la part
je dirais d'autres hommes politiques qui
ont labouré le terrain sur les thèmes
qu'il développent lui-même l'immigration
ben évidemment il y avait Jean-Marie Le
Pen qui a qui en a parlé pendant des
années mais sur les questions de la
démographie on peut remonter plus haut à
Michel Debray sur la question des villes
qui allaient être je dirais détru le
centreville qui allait être détruite par
je dirais les grandes surface aux
alentours il y avait le maire de tour
Jean Royet donc il y a tout un ensemble
d'hommes Politi PI pouade et Pierre
Poujade aussi bien sûr donc si vous
voulez il y a tout un ensemble de
personnes qui avaient labouré le terrain
ensuite il y a un mouvement plus général
de la transformation je dirais des des
des des rapports de forces politiques ce
que j'ai proposé moi d'appeler le
mouvement d'extrogir et dans votre livre
merci et et et en l'occurrence Éric
Zemour et bien profite de ce mouvement
général il y a le talent personnel d'éc
Zemour incontestable il y a le fait
qu'il a été rejoint par un certain
nombre de personnes je pense pas que ça
fasse énormément de transfert de voix
mais en tout cas ça à soit je dirais son
périmètre politique jean-fédéric poisson
Philippe Devillier pour parler des deux
plus important et puis et puis Guillaume
peltiier Nicolas quand même qui était an
ancien numéro 2 respective de leur
partie absolument bon mais disons que
ils avaient je dirais une visibilité
peut-être politique moins grande dans le
sens où il était pas chef d'organisation
politique et il n'avait pas eux-mêm été
candidat soit à une primaire soit à une
présidentielle alors que Jean-Frédéric
Poisson avait été en 2016 candidat à la
primaire de LR et Philippe dev viler
avait été candidat à la présidentielle
et puis et puis et puis pourquoi
l'émergence d'éc Zemour bah tout
simplement parce que l'électorat
conservateur qu'on a vu incarné par r
trochi par exemple et bien il avait été
d'une certaine manière un peu négligé
par Marine Le Pen et donc il y a eu un
appel d'air donc qu'on l'aime ou qu'on
ne l'aime pas de toute façon Zemour est
incontestablement le phénomène politique
après est-ce qu'il va réussir son Paris
ça c'est une autre affaire et on est en
train justement de regarder s'il est en
train de réussir son Paris d'aujourd'hui
on retrouve Timothé Delem qui se trouve
place du trocaderou en tout cas un petit
peu derrière la place du Trocadero parce
que ah déjà de nouveau l'image fige enc
qui est le signe qu'il y a encore de la
densité là où il se là où il se trouve
vous trouvez exactement où
Timothé
l' ja alors nous sommes exactement
avenue Raymond Point Carré donc une des
avenues qui qui donne sur la place du
Trocadero la place du Trocadero qui elle
est est en train de de se remplir
vraiment à vue d'œil là ça devient
vraiment plein et vous voyez derrière
moi sur ces images Raphaël Lazreg qui
vous le montre un deuxème SAS vient
d'ouvrir donc nous nous étions il y a
quelques instants lors de notre
précédente intervention et bien
exactement là où les les services de
sécurité sont en train de de fouiller et
les militants en train de ou les
sympathisants en tout cas qui sont en
train d'arriver sur le Trocadero donc il
y a deux sas là comme vous le voyez sur
ces images afin de faire rentrer un
maximum de de personnes un flux continu
en tout cas nous ça fait ça fait
peut-être 5 10 minutes maintenant qu'on
est et bien au niveau de cette entrée et
les militants qui qui Contin continu
d'arriver voilà et donc à être fouillé
par les services de sécurité et je suis
justement avec un militant qui est
adhérent à à reconquête qui nous dit
suivre éc zimour depuis longtemps depuis
ces années on n pas couché me dites-vous
alors vous dites qu'au début vous
n'étiez pas tout à fait convaincu et que
finalement maintenant vous êtes devenu
vraiment à fond pour é zour pourquoi
alors j'étais pas convaincu pas couché
j'étais jeune j'étais dans l'école
publique j'ai un peu subi la propagande
de
nationale donc c'est le vivre ensemble
et cetera c'est magnifique et c'est vrai
que je dirais depuis 2014 quand j'avais
ans il y a eu des émeutes en juillet
2014 à barbes et je sais pas ça a été le
déclique ça aurait pu être autre chose
et à ce moment-là tout me semblait
évident sauf qu' tout m'a semblé évident
à ce moment-là il y avait que Marine Le
Pen comme choix du pontignant mais
c'était pas un vote très
utile là aujourd'hui je suis bien
content que ERC Zemour parce que au
second tour il sera bien meilleur que
Marine Le Pen en 2017 contre Macron
Macron souhaite une chose il souhaite
être contre Marine Le Pen au second tour
pour encore l'éclater en débat Zemour
est le meilleur débatteur de notre camp
et Marine Le Pen elle s'est totalement
décrédibilisé et les sondages sont pour
moi commandés par Macron pour mettre
Marine Le Pen en tête c'est tout ce que
rêve Macron d'être face à elle qu'est-ce
qui vous marque dans les propositions
d'Éric Zemour qu'est-ce qui fait que
vous adhérez au discours d'Éric Zemour
il a exactement les mêmes priorités pour
la France que moi il veut lutter contre
l'islamisation de la France il veut que
la France reste la France il veut lutter
contre le grand emplacement et inverser
les flux inverser les flux migratoires
que tous ceux qui n'ont pas leur place
en France repartent d'où ils viennent et
on a des moyens de pression comme on
peut interdire les les les remises
Western Union on peut
aussi interdire l'aide au développement
couper l'aide au développement on
peut ne plus donner de visa on a plein
de moyens de pression on est la France
contre des pays en développement vous
parliez tout à l'heure de Marine Le Pen
la candidate du rassemblement national
qu'est-ce qui fait la la différence
entre Eric Zemour Marine Le Pen dans
votre
choix éc Zemour c'est pas quelqu'un
c'est pas une girouette qui va en
fonction des sondages dire essayer de
Zemour est quelqu'un d'intègre c'est
quelqu'un qui c'est pas un un
politicien avec une boutique c'est c'est
quelqu'un s'il se lance c'est vraiment
que il voit que personne d'autre
les Mar Le Pen a tellement de fois
changé d'avis elle est pas sincère elle
est pas
compétente et en plus tous ces cadres
les plus populaires sont partis
maintenant chez Zemour à part Bardella
qui veut garder sa place qui a une bonne
place
mais é Zemour est beaucoup plus crédible
il est beaucoup plus il est beaucoup
plus cultivé il
est Marine Le Pen elle est pas crédible
pour moi
elle est pas crédible et en plus elle a
totalement si je devais Marine Le Pen
elle est pas compétente on l'a bien vu
au débat de second tour contre Macron et
la deuxième chose Marine Le Pen change
tout le temps d'avis et surtout elle est
elle a totalement renoncé à tout elle a
renoncé à Schengen à sortir de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme elle a
renoncé à tout pour moi vous parlez de
crédibilité depuis le début de la guerre
en Ukraine ERC Zemour a été critiqué
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux où on
a vu certaines vidéos ressortir où il
clamaitfin où on voyait en tout cas son
accointance avec Vladimir Poutine le
président de la Russie qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez nous allonsou je pense
qu'Eric Zemour déjà le jour même il a
condamné l'agression de Poutine
puisqu'il défend la souveraineté des
nations la souveraineté des peuple donc
il a eu
raison l'Ukraine est un État souverain
Poutine n'avait pas n'avait aucune
aucune raison aucune justification il
cherche des alibes il y avait aucune
raison de faire
ça ce que ce que Zemour disait de
Poutine avant c'est que c'est un
patriote russe c'est un patriote de son
pays c'est vrai qu'à titre
personnel c'est pas forcément le modèle
que j'aurais parce que
moi par exemple pendant les les manif
contre le Pass sanitaire j'étais pour
les libertés qui ét trop sacrifié et
c'est vrai que en Russie il y a quand
même des libertés sacrifié donc moi je
suis plutôt pour la liberté après
Poutine disons avant l'Ukraine c'est pas
c'est pas Satan je veux dire c'estàd que
c'est quelqu'un qui aime son pays et qui
n'est pas dans un espèce
d'humanisme c'est quelqu'un qui aime son
pays avant tout il défend les intérêts
de son pays même même de
je pense que Zemour prenez comme modèle
Poutine avant parce que parce que parce
que Poutine aime son pays c'est un
patriote de son pays
voilà sur le discours de cet après-midi
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de la prise
de parole d'Éric
Zemour j'attends comme à villeepinte un
discours très maîtrisé une foule
enthousiasmée que ça va être relayé ça
va être un tournant dans la campagne et
ça va surtout éclipser le meeting de
Fabien Rous et jeanl qui me semble ont
lieu aujourd'hui aussi est-ce que vous
pensez qu'Éric Zemour qui est
aujourd'hui à 11 % selon les intentions
de vote est-ce que vous pensez qu'il a
ses chances d'accéder au second tour
alors merci de me poser la question
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure les
les sondages veulent mettre Marine Le
Pen en tête pour nous pousser à voter
utile Marine Le Pen puisque c'est tout
ce que rêve Emmanuel Macron d'être
contre elle et de l'étrier au débat de
second tour moi ce que je dis c'est que
Marine Le Pen a toujours été surestimé
en 2017 on l'a annoncé à 30 elle a fait
21 % au région au dernier régional elle
devait avoir 6 régions sont partis
finalement on a zé elle est tout le
temps surestimée Jean-Marie Le Pen en
2002 bon j'avais 7 ans j'aurais pas
vraiment voté pour lui mais en tout cas
il avait il est annoncé à 8 % il est
annoncé 4e il a été 2e
donc on nous pousse à voter Marine Le
Pen on veut nous faire voter Marine Le
Pen notre camp mais on va pas se faire
avoir et et moi je vous dis qu'on va
avoir une grande surprise et regardez
Fillon en 2017 à la Primare de la droite
on l'annonc même pas au second tour des
primaires de la droite il a été au
second tour des primes de la droite il
les a gagné au la main contre alin Jupé
merci beaucoup on vous laisse et bien
pouvoir accéder à cette place du
Trocadero Vincent comme vous le voyez
derrière moi les militants continuent
d'arriver et d'être fouillé par les
services de de sécurité et on va
peut-être vous montrer également cette
place du Trocadero donc qui se trouve
derrière derrière nous enfin en tout cas
devant moi plutôt voilà cette place donc
qui qui est maintenant rempli on voit
cette marée de drapeau français les
drapeaux bleu blanc rouge qui sont
distribués au an à leur arrivé sur la
place du Trocadero alors que les
interventions à la tribune semblent
s'être terminé c'est maintenant un clip
qui est en train d'être diffusé h écrans
géants sont déployés pour
l'occasion et voilà donc comme vous le
voyez sur ces images plusieurs
intervenants avec un moment un moment
d'acalmie là clairement sur cette place
du
Trocadero effectivement et on continue
d'avoir les images qui nous parviennent
donc de la place du trcadero les vôtres
qui euh sont sont un peu flous parce que
justement il y a du monde et donc la les
les réseaux euh par la transmission
téléphonique qui se fait entre la place
du Trocadero et les studios du figao
sont un peu saturé les autres images par
exemple celle de la FP que vous voyez en
ce moment elle est envoyée par satellite
ce qui permet d'avoir une une meilleure
là en l'occurrence d'avoir une meilleure
vue une meilleure vision on a entendu
également Jacqueline mourau et on a vu
Jacqueline mourau prendre la parole tout
à l'heure pendant que Timothé interview
ce militant peut-être une question
peut-être un commentaire par rapport à
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
Guillaume concernant Jacqueline mourau
vous disiez tout à l'heure il y a
quelque chose peut-être d'un peu trop
parisien dans la démarche d'éc Zemour
qui consiste à être pour reprendre
une une expression de la startup nation
bottom up c'està-dire que on va ou bien
plutôt up bottom c'est-à-dire qu'on va
du haut vers le bas de la de Paris vers
la province néanmoins néanmoins le
mouvement le rassemblement la marche
vers enfin en tout les cas la
manifestation à Paris c'est quelque
chose qui relève de ce mouvement des des
gilets jaunes et qui est éminemment qui
a été un mouvement éminemment populaire
je ne conteste en rien le fait qu'un
candidat à la présidentielle doit va
faire un grand meeting dans une grande
métropole et peut-être même Paris je dis
simplement que de manière globale la
campagne a été derric Zemour a plutôt a
été une campagne de Paris qui part à la
conquête des provinces plus que d'un
candidat qui va écouter les gens en
province voilà c'était un jugement de
manière globale et pas qui visait en
l'occurrence ce ce meeting là il est
certain que il a auprès de lui deux
personnalités monsieur Kochi et Madame
qui ont été dans le mouvement des gilets
jaunes mais enfin il faut bien savoir
que il n'y avait pas de représentant
officiel de ce mouvement qui était qu
Mme a été à l'impulsion elle a été l'une
des personnes je vous rappelle que c'est
un routier dans les essones dans les son
dans le département de l'esson qui a
lancé qui a lancé qui a lancé le
mouvement qui a commencé le 17
novembre 2018 d'utres disent que c'est
ja mourau et et et et il est certain que
c'est un mouvement très décentralisé qui
a rassemblé sur les ronds-points un très
grand nombre de Français euh et il est
étonnant je dois le dire que Éric Zemo
ne reprennent pas l'une des principales
revendications des gilets jaunes à
savoir le fait qu'il y ait un référendum
d'initiative populaire ou d'initiative
citoyenne c'est une des demandes dès le
début du mouvement des gilets jaunes et
j'insiste là-dessus avant même que je
dirais des mouvements très à gauche ne
cherchent à récupérer le mouvement voire
à le détour é dès le début il y avait
une double revendication qui était l'un
l'une de vivre de son travail et l'autre
je dirais de pouvoir participer aux
décisions politiques de pouvoir
s'autosaisir le référendum d'initiative
populaire or Éric Zemmour s'est refusé
de manière catégorique à à mettre cela
dans ses comment dire dans son programme
ce qui explique d'ailleurs que Florient
Philippo est finalement décidé de
soutenir Nicolas dupontaignan et non pas
Eric zemours qui aurait paru peut-être
plus logique ou en tout cas plus propice
à à rebooster à nouveau la campagne ou
la visibilité de Florient Filippo voilà
euh flight nous dit c'est n'est pas un
mouvement parisien du tout reconquête a
affrité plusieurs bus depuis la province
c'est vrai que sur les sites et sur les
réseaux sociaux de de reconquête alors
que Jean Messa
ancien ancien ancien conseiller de
Marine Le Pen rallié depuis très depuis
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois
maintenant éour est en de prendre la
parole on voyait effectivement un
certain nombre de bus partir de ville de
de notamment de métropole régionale je
voudrais qu'on signale une autre chose
en ce moment puce que c'est une
après-midi de meeting et vous si vous
nous rejoignez en ce moment sur le site
du Figaro vous l'avez peut-être vu tout
à l'heure en tête de Home et c'est
également à retrouver dans le corps de
la h maintenant le meeting de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sur la plage du Pr
à Marseille euh et qui est en train donc
qui vient de démarrer et qui est
également à suivre en direct sur le site
du Figaro on voyait tout à l'heure donc
manuel bampard le directeur de sa
campagne euh animé le début de ce
meeting Jean Messia est en ce moment
donc place du
Trocadero sur scène en train de prendre
la parole précisément si on revient à
Mélenchon
euh est-ce que
euh d'abord de votre point de vue est-ce
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon peut se retrouver
au 2e tour du fait notamment de la
candidature d'Éric Zémour alors il y a
plusieurs éléments c'est en tous les cas
ce que disent les proches de mélanchant
ce matin dans le Journal du Dimanche en
disant un zemmourbas euh ce serait
dommage pour nous parce que ça veut dire
une Marine Le Pen haute et donc
l'impossibilité d'accéder au second tour
ce qui est ce qui est désolant premier
commentaire ce qui est désolant c'est
que nos hommes politiques raisonnent
uniquement en terme de vase communicant
et pas en terme de Mobilis ou d'intérêt
de la part des Français c'est-à-dire que
ils ne se disent pas que en fait les
chiffres peuvent varier en fonction je
dirais de la mobilisation des électeurs
et donc de la baisse de l'abstention
mais uniquement en terme de je prends
des parts de marché bon ceci étant dit
oui il est certain
qu'évidemment la présence d'Éric Zemour
l'émergence d'Éric Zemour permet je
dirais d'abaisser d'une certaine manière
le seuil de qualification au 2è tour
puisqu'il prend une partie de
l'électorat euh semble-t-il plus petite
maintenant qu'il y a quelques semaines
mais une partie de l'électorat de de
Marine Le Pen 2uxème élément Jean-Luc
Mélanchon est le seul à connaître une
véritable comment dire progression dans
le fond il est le seul sur la toute la
durée de la campagne a véritablement
progressé tandis que bah Zemour est
plutôt sur la pente douce mais une pente
de
descente Valérie pcrè également Marine
Le Pen elle est aussi quelque peu et
puis Emmanuel Macron qui a beaucoup
progressé il faut bien le dire avec la
question je dirais de de de l'Ukraine et
parce que il y a le vote frileux hein
les partisans de l'ordre le vote
légaliste qui s'est rallié à lui il
connaît maintenant tout de même à
nouveau une petite une petite descente
même s'il est très loin devant ses
autres concurrents pour l'instant en
tout cas dans que c'est votre TR c'est
c'est une opinion c'est un c'est un
point de V c'est c'est c'est c'est
vraiment je dirais le le le ce que
j'appelle le vote frileux alors oui
c'est une expression qui est personnelle
mais c'est c'est c'est le parti de
l'ordre c'est le vote légaliste
c'est-à-dire c'est on vote pour celui
qui est en place parce que on est dans
une situation incertaine et que on ne
veut pas changer de de de personnel
politique voilà c'est une frilosité qui
je dirais bénéficie à aux sortant tout
simplement et c'est le même phénomène
que celui qu'on a eu lorsqu'il y a eu
une énorme abstention euh au municipal
ou aux élections départementales et
régionales les sortants ont très
grandement profité je dirais de de d'une
d'une forte absention donc euh Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il progresse mais par rapport
à 2017 il s'est mis à progresser plus
tardivement dans la campagne que ce
qu'il n'avait fait il y a 5 ans
autrement dit
euh il progresse mais comme il ne reste
plus que 15 jours est-ce que ça va être
suffisant pour atteindre le niveau de
Marine Le Pen et la dépasser ça ça n'est
pas tout à fait certain et pour
l'instant on n'est pas encore tout à
fait dans les marches d'erreur
c'est-à-dire que si les candidats
étaient à trois points on pourrait dire
qu'effectivement il y a des marges
d'erreurs dans les sondages qui font que
bah il est tout à fait possible que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon soit devant Marine Le
Pen mais pour l'st ce qu'on appelle une
marge d'erreur Guillaume c'est plus ou
moins plus ou moins 3 % c'estàd que si
par exemple Jean-Luc Mélenchon est
mettons crédité de 13 % il peut monter
jusqu'à 16 % mais il peut descendre à 10
%
alors quand on est entre 10 et 20 % la
marge d'erreur est généralement
considérée de à peu près de 2 quand on a
un échantillon représentatif interrogé
de 1000 personnes plus on se rapproche
de 0 ou de 100
% moins la marge d'erreur est grande
plus on se rapproche de 50 % plus la
marge d'erreur est grande et c'est pour
ça que quand on nous dit les sondages se
trompent tout le temps parce qu'il nous
annonce 48 52 ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que les instituts de
sondage eux ont la précaution d'un
indiquer leur marge d'erreur et il
pensent que ça va plutôt pencher d'un
côté que de l'autre mais malheureusement
et pardonnez-moi de le dire ici au
Figaro mais vos confrères journalistes
chers Vincent n'ont pas toujours la
précaution d'indiquer qu'il y a une
marge d'erreur et donc quand on est à 48
52 en fait tout est tout est
parfaitement tout est parfaitement
jouable je vous laisse la responsabilité
de vos propos mais en tous les cas au
Figaro on tâche toujours de le préciser
et c'est ce qu'on est en train non
seulement on le précise mais ce qu'on
fait plus rarement on l'explique ce
qu'on est en train de faire
exactement et voilà euh peut-être dans
le chat actuellement on essaie de
retrouver Timothé dem mais la preuve que
il y a quand même je pense du du monde
c'est que on a encore du de la de
l'image qui a figé et la FP a le même
problème apparemment euh et donc on est
pour l'instant sur les images de
campagne du candidat Éric Zemour n'a
plus de na plus de dynamique nous dit
justement Éric sur le chat et flight lui
répond Fillon a explosé dans les deux
jours qui ont précédé les les scrutins
des primaires euh explosé donc en
haièreière effectivement asentionnel
est-ce que on peut dire aujourd'hui
qu'Eric Zemour n'a plus de
dynamique dans dans le sens
où il comment dire il semble qu'il
patine qu'il a eu des difficultés à se
positionner sur un certain nombre de
sujets et et qu'il a commis tout de même
un certain nombre de maladresse je
dirais dans ses déplacements et dans les
choix de ces déplacements oui on peut
dire que sa dynamique est en quelque peu
enrayée il n'est pas allé à l'invitation
de l'association des mires de France il
n'est pas allé à l'invitation de la
Fédération Nationale des Travaux Publics
et il n'est pas allé à l'invitation de
la CGP de la CPME la Confédération des
petites et moyennes entreprises
c'est-à-dire que voilà des éléments qui
moi me font dire et peut-être que les
les téléspectateurs comprendront mieux
ce que je voulais dire tout à l'heure en
parlant de mouvement parisien euh qui se
veut horors système et qui est parfois
un peu plus hors sol que hors système
euh disons que il c'est une campagne qui
préfère les grands messes euh militante
que je dirais la constitution de réseau
le fait de snober les comment dire les
maires alors qu'ils ont obtenu une
extrémiste les signatures pour pouvoir
être candidat le fait de snober les
patrons de TPE et PME qui sont desid des
dévidents relais d'opinion en province
c'était me semble-t-il de la part de son
équipe est-ce une décision de d'Éric
Zemmour seul ou de son équipe ça je ne
je ne peux pas le dire mais c'est me
semble Marine Le Pen dit que l'une des
causes de sa piètre performance et au
débat face à Emmanuel Macron et d'avoir
multiplié ce
genre
rendez-vousir été fatigué on va écouter
Gilbert card qui prend la parole
actuellement sur la sur la place du
Trocadero et avant
de d'y revenir 15h23 sur le site du
Figaro puisqu'on a changé d'heure
et Eric Zemour lui devrait prendre la
parole aux alentours de
16h est prévu également de s'adresser
devant la foule du tradero juste avant
le cand
Mar Marchal et également Philippe deer
on écoute
Gilbert leses sur la colline du craque
il est
l'homme il est l'homme qui ne courbe pas
les chines contre les violences de rue
contre la violence des lobbyes contre la
violence des racailles contre la
violence du terrorisme contre la
violence des mensonges et contre la
violence
du déis de la France bravo à l'homme qui
marche seul non avec vous par vous grâce
à vous merci
merci aujourd'hui
oui mais oui on va
[Applaudissements]
gagner
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il
avance sous cette fragile armure de mots
d'idées d'histoire de France D'Amour de
la patrie de notion du réel il avance
sous les insultes sale juif chien il
avance sous les violences il avance sous
les mensonges il avance sous les
crachats mais il est la France qui
avance et qui va
reconquérir écoutez
écoutez vous qui êtes ici et au-delà de
vous tous ceux qui sont ici vous êtes la
France
insondable
inattendu
invisible la France de la force la
France de la reconquête la France qui
dit oui à la
France ils vous disent que ce n'est pas
possible ils vous disent que l'avenir
voilà donc on vient d'entendre Gilbert
Collard ça fait partie il y a il y a
quand même une question qu'on peut se
poser Guillaume c'est que ces
personnalités comme Gilbert Collard
Gilbert Collard était est député depuis
2012 hein donc il a été réélu en en 2017
euh les d'autres personnes comme
Stéphane Ravier avant Nicolas B
également ont quitté le rassemblement
national où ils avaient l'un mandat
l'assurance d'un mandat même si ils
étaient relégués par Marine Le Pen même
si les relations n'étaient pas bonnes
avec Marine Le Pen ils ont pris quand
même un sacré risque en quittant le
rassemblement national par rapport à
leur à leur mandat et par rapport à leur
carrière politique oui c'est c'est c'est
certain je pense que il y a et on l'a
bien je par également de Guillaume
Peltier qui était quand même une des un
des dirigeants de des ré ré des
républicains alors deux choses à dire la
première c'est que les
rallimentss hormis lorsque ce sont des
personnalités vraiment de premier ordre
je pense par par exemple à François
Baayou qui était présidentiable qui
était candidat qui avait fait 17 % en
201 dans 2007 qui était de nouveau
crédité d'au moins 5 % en
2017 hormis ces cas-là le rallimement
d'une personnalité à un parti politique
ou à un candidat ça ne transforme pas je
dirais énormément les SCOR voilà ça je
on l'avait déjà évoqué la deuxième chose
et c'est ce que vous évoquez là
maintenant c'est le fait qu'il y a
effectivement un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont considéré qu'il
fallait recomposer la vie politique et
que je ne sais pas s'ils se sont dit nos
carrières passent après et en tout cas
ça serait tout à leur honneur mais qu'il
fallait essayer de je dirais
décloisonner les partis politiques et
ils ont trouvé dans éc Zemmour la
possibilité et bien de de le faire il
est certain qu'il y a une chose que je
trouve assez étonnante c'est que
personne ne le dit euh notamment
lorsqu'ils interrogent aussi bien Éric
Zemmour lorsqu'il a eu des ralliments
que Marine Le Pen lorsqu'elle a eu des
défections euh personne de vos confrères
n'évoque le fait que le cordon sanitaire
qui entourer le Front national le
rassemblement national est quasiment
mort s'il y a un cordon sanitaire ça
signifie que ce sont entre guillemets
des fasciste qui qui rallie HC Zémour or
ça n'est pas le cas ou plutôt ça n'est
pas ce qu'on lui dit ce qui signifie que
le cordon sanitaire est quasiment mort
et que Eric Zemour a contribué
incontestablement à la recomposition
est-ce que cette reconquête qui sera le
parti qui arrivera au pouvoir en faisant
cette recomposition moi je n'en ai pas
le sentiment je pense que c'est une
première étape dans une recomposition
politique et que ensuite il y aura
d'autres événements qui devront avoir
lieu pour que cette droite nationale qui
va constituer malgré sa division au soir
du premier tour de la présidentielle la
première force politique Marine Le Pen
éc Zemour Nicolas duponteignan peut-être
une partie de l'électorat jean- Lassal
ce sera le premier vol ça pas beaucoup
une partie de l'électorat jean-lal c'est
vrai mais je je l'aime beaucoup
personnellement et donc par conséquent
je ne pouvais pas ne pas le citer en
tout cas en tout cas ça sera la première
force politique du pays et par
conséquent devant devant Emmanuel Macron
mais une force politique divisée et donc
la recomposition finale elle se fera par
la réunification de toutes ces forces
reconquête ne sera pas ne sera qu'une
étape dans cette recomposition l'ancien
député viliériste puis UMP rallé par la
suite au front et rassemblement national
Jérôme rivière est en train de prendre
la parole et de s'exprimer sur la place
du
Trocadero on va y revenir euh on attend
d'avoir également des images de nos
envoyés spéciaux mais qui sont également
euh pris et dans la dans la foule et
dans la saturation des réseaux 4G
comment
euh Guillaume une autre question qui qui
se pose euh vous venez de l'aborder euh
30 % c'est environ le euh en ce moment
quand on fait les additions euh dans les
sondages ce que pèse ce camp qui est la
droite hors UMP
euh première observation par rapport à à
ce phénomène cette droite hors UMP elle
est majoritaire euh aujourd'hui euh
cette droite or LR elle est majoritaire
à droite c'estàdire que LR qui était le
centre de gravité euh de de la droite et
glisse de la droite vers la gauche c'est
ce que j'ai proposé d'appeler le
mouvement d'extrogir la pression
idéologique vient par la droite et
toutes les l'espace politique de la
droite la plus radicale s'élargit et les
forces politiques plus anciennes soit
disparaissent soit glisse vers la gauche
du spectre politique il y a quand même
une droitisation également du discours
de chez chez LR et chez Valérie PEC
absolument et j'ai rarement vu une
primaire de la droite modérée aussi à
droite que celle de cette année oui euh
quoi vous êtes alors justement c'est
donc la thèse que vous défendez dans
votre livre encore une fois on le
recommande le mouvement d'extrogir on le
recommande d'autant plus facilement que
il a ce livre à 5 ans mais il n'a pas
pris une ride il y a un certain nombre
de phénomènes qui ne sont pas analysés
mais qui sont annoncés c'est ça qui est
très intéressant je prends l'exemple
notamment des gilets jaunes qui sont
anticipésère oui absolument sans le
nom votre livre ah ben non ça on pouvait
pas on pouvait pas il le nom qu'on
pouvait pas inventer mais en tous les
cas tous les ingrédients et toutes les
thématiques l'insécurité sociale hein
est abordée dès le début de votre de
votre livre on y reviendra peut-être
justement parce que sur sur les
thématiques de campagne qui sont en
train de de s'imposer euh à quoi
attribuez-vous le le fait que
aujourd'hui ce camp-là euh et Dominique
reéier de la fond d'aple va jusqu'à lui
agréger le camp mélenchant dans un camp
qu'on pourrait appeler le camp de la
colère social euh mais comment euh vous
vous expliquez le fait que ce camp euh
droite horors euh républicain atteignent
30 % c'est-à-dire 1/3 de l'électorat
français alors j'auris envie de vous
donner une réponse facile mais qui est
en en grande partie la réponse c'est que
les thèmes qui ont été développés par ce
camp politique là euh se sont révélés
être ce qui était prgant dans la société
c'est-à-dire l'insécurité des personnes
et des biens l'insécurité économique et
sociale euh le chômage la popérisation
des classes moyennes et puis
l'insécurité culturelle et morale elle
est due aussi bien effectivement à une
immigration de de peuplement qu'à un
déracinement des populations autochtones
par la standardisation je dirais des de
la consommation ou ou ou autres
phénomènes de ce genre et j'aurais envie
de rajouter à ces trois insécurités euh
une 4è qui est une insécurité d'ordre
juridique c'est-à-dire des libertés
publiques des libertés individuelles
c'est pas exactement la même chose mais
les deux sont à évoquer qui sont sujets
à caution qui du moins ne sont pas
toujours assurés euh par je dirais
l'ordre l'ordre politique euh on l'a vu
avec et bien la crise la crise sanitaire
c'est c'est ces deux dernières années et
une tendance à je dirais une
surveillance dans la société qui est de
plus en plus de plus en plus importante
ces insécurités-là correspondent à la
réalité de ce que vit je dirais les
Français et euh bah il est certain que
un discours qui se veut plus réaliste
qui se veut plus pragmatique que d'cun
pourrait qualifier de démagogique hein
ou de populiste et bien ce discoursl
évidemment il progresse dans l'opinion
publique et puis et puis après il y a un
deuxième élément qu'il ne faut pas
oublier c'est que euh un certain nombre
de propositions lorsqu'elles sont
présentées en aveugle c'est-à-dire sans
étiquette politique et qui sont des
propositions véritablement de droite ou
authentiquement de droite elles sont
approuvé très majoritairement dans
l'opinion publique depuis un certain
nombre d'années en revanche et ça c'est
vrai il y a un comment dire une baisse
d'adhésion lorsqu'elles sont étiqueté
politiquement que ce soit LR que ce soit
le rassemblement national ou que ce soit
maintenant reconquête et euh c'est donc
je dirais une défiance envers les partis
politiques qui euh expliquent évidemment
que les partis les plus plus extrêm que
les partis nouveaux puissent attirer
cela dit il n'attirent pas encore
suffisamment pour mobiliser les
absenstionniste il y a toute une partie
de la population qui ne ne s'y retrouve
pas malgré une nouvelle offre politique
on reviendra justement sur cette
question des abstentionnistes vous êtes
nombreux à poser la question notamment
de ce de de ce de cette notion ce
concept du vote caché je vous promets on
va y revenir on va aller place du
Trocadero ambiance et on va écouter
Jean-Frédéric Poisson qui est en train
de de prendre la
parole contre les délires de la
propagande qui s'installe dans nos
écoles contre la précarisation
incessante que subissent nos concitoyens
qui n'ont pas les moyens de pouvoir
vivre tout seul et assurer les
conditions de leur existence alors c'est
très simple mes amis voilà ce que nous
devons dire pendant 15 jours à tous nos
compatriotes nous ne voulons plus de
cette France- là dans laquelle nous
sommes forcés de vivre nous ne voulons
plus de la France dépasse de toutes
sortes de l'obligation vaccinale larvée
nous ne voulons plus de cette France qui
oublie les Français qui oublie notre
histoire et nos traditions nous voulons
en un mot qu'Eric Zemour soit président
de la République le 24 avril prochain
vive erriic Zemour vive la
[Applaudissements]
France
our vous êtes nombreux également à nous
suivre sur le compte Youtube du Figaro
alors peut-être d'ailleurs ça illustre
ce que dit un un internaute sur sur la
page Youtube quel que soit le score d'éc
Zemour sa campagne aura été une réussite
et en particulier euh notamment euh
peut-être
euh Guillaume sur les réseaux sociaux
alors oui euh du point de vue militant
c'est-à-dire réussir à engrger à à
engranger des adhésions et avoir une
présence militante sur le terrain
collage d'affiche distribution de tract
et cetera il est certain que reconquête
est l'un des partis les plus dynamiques
aujourd'hui qui soit c'est très clair
euh il a agrégé des gens qui étaient en
désérance soit de LR soit des déçus on
l'a entendu tout à l'heure je dirais un
militant qui a été interrogé par Timothé
et qu' qu' l'a très bien dit je dire on
l'a très bien ressenti il a même dit
explicitement il y a une défiance envers
Marine Le Pen qui fait que ces je dirais
militants là se sont mis véritablement à
militer pour pour Éric Zemmour donc ça
du point de vue de la constitution d'un
mouvement militant c'est incestable une
réussite ensuite la présence sur les
réseaux sociaux alors ça ne fait pas
tout euh parce qu'évidemment on a tous
en tête le cas de de Donald Trump qui a
contourné les médias
mainstream qui s'est même attaqué à eux
et qui a réussi à gagner la
présidentielle aux États-Unis en 2016
notamment par une très forte présence
sur je dirais les médias 10 alternatifs
et les réseaux sociaux pour ce qui est
je dirais de l'équipe qui entour et qui
suit Samuel Lafond il y a
incontestablement une vraie réussite il
est il est vrai qu'il avait fait ses
armes auparavant euh
avec une comment dire une un un pédigré
d'amoclesès hein qui est assez connu euh
avec d'autres d'autres choses qu'il
avait organisé les années précédentes et
donc il est très aguéri à cela
simplement mais est-ce que là il y a pas
quelque chose qui est un signe des temps
aussi hein c'est que les campagnes euh
se font euh elles se font aussi là elles
se font maintenant même principalement
là vous disiez tout à l'heure que
euh le fait de ne pas s'être exprimé
devant un certain nombre de fédérations
professionnelles de pas avoir multiplié
justement les prises de parole
catégorielle
finalement mais auprès de gens qui sont
des relais et qui sont des relais
sociaux qui sont des leaders d'opinion
locaux je crois que c'était une erreur
de sa part mais bon voilà mais bien sûr
les les les réseaux sociaux ça compte
énormément mais ça touche un certain
type de population et et on le sait bien
alors là pour le coup je je sors une
science qui n'est pas la mienne mais je
ne fait que répéter ce que l'on m'a
appris chacun des réseaux socials touche
une certaine catégorie de la population
Twitter c'est plutôt le personnel
politique les journaliste et Instagram
c'est plutôt les jeunes Facebook c'est
plutôt le réseau famille comment dire et
personnes et personnes plus âgées bon
les jeunes c'est plutôt TikTok
maintenant c'est même TikTok voyez je
suis même dépassé mais ils sont ils sont
également présents sur
et et donc et donc euh là c'est
incontestablement une réussite mais
attention pardonnez-moi de dire je parle
également pour pour l'équipe Mélanchon
où ils sont extrêmement présents et il y
a une campagne numérique et qui a
toujours été d'un point de vue
technologique très avancé c'est certain
euh simplement c'est un support ce sont
des relais c'est pas ce qui fait
véritablement euh je dirais le le le la
la présence dans les esprit des dans
dans les esprits des électeurs euh je
suis désolé d'y revenir sans arrêt mais
pour l'instant nous avons le plus fort
d'abstention potentielle pour une
présidentielle dans les 15 jours qui
viendront il y aura peut-être une
diminution de cette abstention mais ça
n'empêche que pour l'instant même des
nouvelles forces politiques comme
reconquête n'ont pas réussi à et bien
diminuer cette abstention là et je crois
que la différence parce que ça c'est un
thème important qui est très souvent
évoqué par les équipe de Zemour pour
dire nous faisons une campagne à la
Trump je suis regret de de de voir les
contredire
sur certains points c'est vrai sur
d'autres points ça n'est pas exact parce
que Trump n'hésitait pas à cliver sur
l'ensemble des sujets tandis que Eric
Zemour a sélectionné par honnêteté sans
dout et par loyauté intellectuelle les
sujets sur lesqueles il voulait cliver
tandis qu'il a essayé d'esquiver parfois
les circonstances l'ont obligé à prendre
position tout de même mais a essayé
d'exquiver les sujets sur lesquels il ne
voulait pas cliver exemple le Pass
sanitaire ou ce genre de chose donc il y
a une différence
entre la campagne trumpiste c'est-à-dire
où systématiquement Trump a cherché à
cliver pour que le choix soit clair et
pour que chaque personne en fonction de
son propre sujet de son propre intérêt
sur telle ou telle question prioritaire
et bien puisse voter pour lui ou le
rejeter tandis que là il y avait une
stratégie plus ciblée sur je dirais une
forme de comment dire de dénonciation
évidemment de l'islamisme et d'autre
part une forme je dirais de défense d'un
état bonapartiste autoritaire enfin
disons puissant pour assurer la sécurité
voilà les deux angles de de de du
clivage que Zemour a imposé signe que on
s'oriente vers donc la prise de parole
du candidat maintenant c'est les poids
lourds de l'organisation qui Prenn la
parole Nicolas B donc ancien secrétaire
général du frontc National ancien
responsable des
eurodéputés rassemblement national au
Parlement européen est en train de
prendre la parole aucun parti ne peut
prétendre rassembler autant de français
et d'ailleurs aucun de nos concurrents à
droite n'a même
essayer étudiants retraités
fonctionnaires cadres ouvriers
agriculteurs hommes et femmes de France
votre présence cet après-midi est la
meilleure et la plus spectaculaire des
réponses à la valce quotidienne des
sondages qui finit par empêcher le vrai
débat sur les vrais enjeux de cette
élection
présidentielle oui mes chers amisous les
dynamique nous sommes la surprise qui
vient et nous allons priver Emmanuel
Macron du confortable et répétitif duel
du deuxème tour dont il
rêve votre présence votre enthousiasme
votre ferveur ici aujourd'hui sont une
magnifique réponse à l'appel d'éc Zemour
mais votre mobilisation dépasse cet
enjeu majeur vous êtes là parce que
convaincu ou simple curieux vous sentez
que notre pays est aujourd'hui à la
croisée des chemin vous n'êtes pas
qu'une foule rassemblée vous êtes un
peuple qui répond présent un peuple qui
a compris que le 10 et le 24 avril
prochain ce n'est pas seulement une
élection c'est un rendez-vous avec
l'Histoire avec notre
histoire et l'histoire nous enseigne que
les civilisations et les nations peuvent
périr nous sommes entrés dans le temps
de l'urgence la France n'a plus de temps
à perdre l'avenir nous est compté
voulez-vous le voir se disloquer pays
dans les prochaines
années sous le poid conjugué de la
submersion migratoire par le sud du
dictat mondialiste de Bruxelles ou bien
voulez-vous reconquérir la
France voulez-vous baisser la tête ou
bien voulez-vous libérer votre
pays pour la gauche pour la gauche de
Mélenchon à Macron défendre son peuple
et sa nation est un crime idéologique et
parfois même un dél
pén mais les criminels mes chers amis ce
sont eux eux qui livrent les Français à
la délinquance étrangère eux qui
n'assument plus les missions
fondamentales de protection des
frontières la police et la justice eux
qui ont abandonné l'idée même de l'État
et de l'action publique puisqu'il ne
gouverne pas il gère il gère d'ailleurs
souvent très mal selon les
recommandations de cabinet privé et les
ordres de la Commission
européenne
nous sommes mes chers amis le pays le
plus imposé au monde la moitié de notre
richesse nationale est confisquée par
l'impôt partant se noyer dans un océan
de dette de gaspillage et d'achat de la
paix civile éphémère dans des cités où
la loi des barbus et celle des dealers a
remplacé nos lois nos mur et nos
traditions écœuré par les trahisons des
uns et les renoncement des autres
beaucoup de Français se laissent envahir
par le fatalisme comme si le le décl
était inéluctable mais impossible n'est
pas français et ERC Zemour incarne
l'espoir la sincérité la lucidité et la
capacité à
rassembler la lucidité c'est aussi
d'apporter des réponses à la hauteur de
la gravité de la situation oui mes chers
amis avec Emmanuel Macron 2 millions
d'étrangers sont entrés en 5 ans et bien
et bien qu'il soit clandestin
délinquants criminel djihadistes erour
organisera la remigration
n plus rien à
faireance car lamigration n'est pas un
concept mais une nécessité
vitale et
[Applaudissements]
prétendre la prétendre antirépublicaine
comme l'a fait Marine Le Pen c'est
parler comme la gauche et nous l'avons
vu ces 30 dernières années quand on
parle comme la gauche finit toujours par
agir comme la
gauche la la rmigration de tiers des
Français la veulent et exemour lui est
animé par cette inébranlable volonté
politique il a une vision du destin il
est l'antimacron face à la nation
startup open space du monde entier il
est le candidat de la grande Histoire et
de l'identité face aux apprentis sorcier
macroniste qui assume le le de vouloir
transformer la France en utilisant notre
peuple comme
et bien nous nous savons que nous sommes
non pas les propriétaires mais
simplement les dépositaires d'un
héritage fabuleux qu' nous appartient de
préserver d'embellir et de transmettre
aux générations
futures et il est aussi le candidat des
familles trop longtemps sacrifié oui
nous protégerons la jeunesse de France
de l'activisme LGBT et des idéologies
délirante sur la
trans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on revient dans les studios du du Figaro
pendant
que les prochains orateurs en attendant
que les prochains orateurs reviennent
sur scène donc on vient d'entendre
Nicolas B qui a déroulé un certain
nombre de de thématiques
classiques pour ce qui était le
rassemblement national dans ce qu'il
avait de plus conservateur on va dire
oui c'est
ça je crois que effectivement cet
après-midi on a toute la palette je
dirais de tous les segments qui sont
représentés de ce que Eric Zemour essae
de de rassembler d'un point de vue je
dirais idéologique on a
effectivement le le le le le le
Jean-Frédéric Poisson pour les
catholiques sociaux on a Nicolas B pour
je dirais les les le rassemblement
national mais plutôt version
conservateur et
cetera la seule chose et ça c'est un des
enjeux c'est est-ce que cela entraine
je dirais une coagulation de ses
électorats
al on va redcuter on voit que Guillaume
Peltier est en train de prendre la
parole effectivement là on a des images
en différé en léger différé l'ancien
donc vice-président des républicain qui
a rallé éic Zemour après le meeting de
ville croyait seul puis ce fut une
rumeur un murmure une promesse et
soudain vous voilà innombrable joyeux
immense à perte de
vue et soudain venu de nos provinces et
de nos villages vous avez répondu à
l'appel du futur président de la
République monsieur Éric
Zemmour et soudain sont apparus les vrai
visage du vote
caché vous étiez le peuple caché vous
êtes aujourd'hui le peuple
debout vous étiez l'armée des ombres
vous êtes l'armée de
lumière vous êtes la droite vous êtes la
France vous êtes les
Français vous êtes le
printemps vous êtes le soleil
[Musique]
d'usterlitz vous êtes la promesse du
Trocadero
c'est le nom d'un cheval au galau
Trocadero c'est le nom de nos pères et
de nos grands-pères qui nous regardent
et qui nous disent vous n'avez pas le
droit de laisser la France s'éteindre et
mourir
Trocadero c'est le nom de nos mères de
nos femmes et de nos filles qui nous
suppli de les protéger des racaille de
la soumission et du voile
islamique
Trocadero c'est le nom de nos fils et de
nos filles qui nous regardent et qui
nous disent
papa seras-tu fidèle aux promesses de
ton baptême sauras-tu nous transmettre
la France sauras-tu nous permettre de
rester français aura-t-on encore le
droit de connaître nos histoires
millénaires viillon Corneille racine
châteaubillant Baudel Hugo
sirano et nous pourons leur répondre oui
mon fils avec er Zemour la France n'est
pas amusée elle est une
épopée la
France la France n'est pas un mirage
elle est un miracle la France n'est pas
un rêve elle est une espérance elle est
une promesse et cette espérance elle ne
déçoit
jamais alors
oui vous êtes des dizaines des dizaines
de
milliers et dans 14 jours à
l'aube nous serons des millions à venir
glisser dans l'urne souveraine le
bulletin de la France oui avec éic
Zemour demain d Lau à l'heure où
blanchit la campagne je
partirai j'irai par la forêt j'irai par
la montagne tu je sais que tu m'attends
je ne puis ma France demeurer loin de
toi plus
longtemps ma France ma France c'est la
fille aînée de l'Église née il y a 2000
ans né il y a 2000 ans dans les trois
souvenirs de Rome d'Athène et de
Jérusalem dans l'étof des songes de
l'amour de Clovis et de sain
clotildde ma France c'est le pays de
Notre-Dame du monts-michel et de
veisely ma France à chaque fois qu'on a
cru fini elle a étonné le monde ma
France c'est le pays du courage de
l'audace de maringo de rivolie et du
pont d'Arcole
oui mes chers
amis imaginons un seul
instant
imaginons un seul
instant fermez les yeux ouvrez les
livres
d'histoire nous sommes un matin de
novembre
1796 il fait froid et l'air est
triste les armées d'Autriche semblent
l'emporter aux yeux de l'Europe toute
entière et soudain le général en chef
Napoléon Bonaparte descend de
tire son sabre se saisit du drapeau
tricolore et s'élance sur le pont sous
une pluie de feu les Autrichiens
reculent et les armées de France
l'emportent
oui Trocadero c'est le nom d'un cheval
au Galot voici venu l'heure de l'ultime
chevauchée voici venu l'heure de la
victoire
nous avons rendez-vous avec la France
nous avons rendez-vous avec
l'Histoire
avecour nous allons chanter la
Marseillaise et comme sur le pont d'arol
nous allons brandir nos drapeau
tricolore qui mieux que lui qui d'autre
que lui qui
mieuxour qui
d'autreour pour nous protéger pour être
courageux et pour la France personne et
je vais vous dire pourquoi parce qu'Eric
Zemour est le seul à avoir eu le courage
de voir il est aujourd'hui le seul à
avoir le courage de dire et demain il
sera le seul à avoir le courage de
[Musique]
faire alors n'ayons pas peur partons au
large sur nos chemins sur nos routes aux
portes de de nos maison pour convaincre
convaincre encore convaincre toujours en
avant le point levé le regard fier la
tête haute en avant le drapeau au vent
le cœur au joie et l'âme en
espérance debout les petits debout les
humbles debout les ouvriers les paysans
debout les invisibles et les Invincibles
debout nos pères et nos grands-pères
debout nos fils et nos filles nous
sommes après la nuit nous sommes avant
le jour ni vous sans
ni nous sans vous un pour tous et tous
pour un vive la victoire du Trocadero
vive le pond d'Arcole vive é Zémour vive
la république et surtout vive la
[Applaudissements]
France mesdames et messieurs est voilà
et Philippe deviler va prendre la parole
on le voit déjà s'approcher de la scène
peut-être un com un court commentaire
Guillaume Peltier le Trocadero il
connaît parce que c'est deux événements
où il a participé précédemment
absolument je dirais que pour avoir
écouté son discours c'est un mélange
entre je dirais une veine Sarco et une
veine Villier Villier Philippe de
Villier qui va prendre la parole
maintenant et d'une certaine manière
aussi sur j'uris le courage il aura le
courage de faire il a eu le courage de
voir
effectivement tout tout je dirais tout
toute l'expérience politique ou toute
l'évolution politique n'est-ce pas de
Guillaume Peltier qui était présente
dans ce discours dont il faut dire qu'il
était assez efficace et qu'il avait
qu'il a su peser peser ses mots et et
poser sa voix on va écouter Philippe
Devillier donc qui prend la parole en ce
moment place du
Trocadero vous êtes mon cadeau
d'anniversaire
regardez derrière moi devant vous làbas
au fond la tourelle
elle vous contemple éah
elle vous contemple
elle en tremble
d'émotion parce que
personne ne vous avez vu venir vous êtes
je salue la Tourel salue la France du
vote
caché du Trocadero est trop
petite elle déborde sur les rues
adjacentes Paris est inondé par des
dizaines de milliers de soleil le
vent et ce sont toutes les provinces de
France qui ont
apporté en provision leur petit coin de
ciel
bleu ah elle est belle la revanche de ce
qu'on a appelé la droite
Trocadero quel contraste avec la gauche
hiidalgo la gauche
Idalgo elle a fermé les volets pour la
journée
elle prend sa
tisane où elle s'adonne au vélo
d'appartement pour décarboner les
synapsus du
Boboland
je voudrais qu'on ait une pensée pour le
maire de
Paris lorsque nous nous
réunissons la place du trucadero ne
suffit pas lorsqu'elle veut réunir son
congrès avec ses amis un abri à
trtinette
suffira mes chers amis le choix que nous
allons faire dans 15 jours
ou bien on bascule dans le vide ou bien
on retrouve la chève de la survie et
c'est la raison pour lesquelle je
voudrais en quelques mots en quelques
phrases vous dire pourquoi il faut
choisir comme chef de l'État ERC
Zemour la première raison c'est que il
nomme le réel il est le seul à nommer le
réel il dit ce qu'il voit et ce qu'il
voit c'est que la France est au bord de
la bîe que la France peut disparaître
submergée de l'extérieur rongé de
l'intérieur que la France peut-être
remplacée nous assistons en réalité à
trois remplacements le remplacement
d'une population par une autre le
remplacement d'une civilisation par une
autre et le remplacement d'une société
par une autre la société de voisinage
remplacé remplacé chers amis par une
société froide une société distanciée
digitalisé
désaffilié la société macronienne de
l'eugénisme de l'hygiénisme d'État et du
posthumanisme une société une société
dans laquelle demain peut-être l'animal
le petit hamster le poisson rouge
d'appartement aura plus de droit que le
petit
homme
alors la deuxème
raison pour laquelle il faut
voter Eric Zemour c'est que il se
contente pas de dire les choses il veut
sauver la France et c'est le seul à
vouloir et à pouvoir sauver la France
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire sauver la
France sauver notre civilisation pour
sauver notre civilisation il faut avoir
demain le droit comme hier de se
souvenir le droit de célébrer ses
souvenirs le droit de célébrer notre
culture le droit de glorifier le chédèv
que nos Aï nous ont légué en
héritage le droit de ne pas mettre le
genoux à terre devant les néoracistes de
la cancelle culture qui veulent
coloniser la
France avoir le droit de pratiquer notre
art de vivre de préférer les cafés au
kebab parce que dans les cafés on peut
serrer la main des
femmes
le droit d'aimer les sapins de Noël le
Tour de France et les statutes de
Saint-Michel le droit de préférer le
bourdon de NotreDame qui son la
libération de Paris au Mozin de
crille le droit de vivre en France comme
des Français c'est cela qu'erc Zemour le
chef de l'État apportera comme garantie
à tous les Français que nous
sommes
mais il y a une autre
raison de faire le choix d'éic
[Applaudissements]
Zemour il y a une autre raison c'est que
il est un des derniers chers amis et
vous le sentez bien
incarner ourage français la preuve c'est
le seul qui va là où il va et où les
autres ne vont pas il va en banlieu il
va au contact il va dans les points
névralgiques et quand je l'ai vu
avantier sur la colline du cque face au
mur de la honte il déambulait il avait
choisi de ne pas prévenir les forces de
l'ordre il est allé tout droit jamais de
marche arrière j' pas de côté et là je
me suis dit et là je me suis dit
cet homme là voilà pourquoi je l'aime
voilà pourquoi je l'admire voilà
pourquoi ils sont des milliers des
millions à le
suivre chers
amis si le panage français existe encore
alors il incarne le panage
français et je terminerai en vous disant
ceci s'il vous plaît de
grâce je vous en supplie
aidez-nous
aidez-le vous la France du sursaut vous
la France des consciences dressées qui
ne veulent plus de ces idéologues qui
accélèrent la déshumanisation
progressive du monde par l'effacement
planifié du visage de
l'homme est on est là on est là on est
là est
est
on est là oui on est là et on sera là et
on sera là dans quelques semaines tous
ensemble vous la France de toujours vous
la France de Zemour pour aller ensemble
faire flotter là-haut tout là-haut en
haut de la Tour Effel le panage français
zour la France
merci
les
[Applaudissements]
amis
mes amis nous y
sommes c'est la dernière ligne
droite c'est
l'heure pour nous tous de choisir
entre la continuité et le changement
entre le déclassement et le redressement
entre la soumission ou la
reconquête c'est l'heure du choix
décisif entre ceux qui ont affaibli la
France ou qui n'ont jamais pu gagner et
entre éic Zemour éc qui a déjà déjoué
les pronostics qui a rebattu les cartes
qui a perturbé le scénario bien huilé
écrit depuis maintenant 5 ans et c'est
pour ces raisons qu'ils veulent vous
convaincre que votre vote est inutile
que l'élection est déjà écrite je vous
pose la question accepterez-vous d'être
hypnotisé c'est toujours la même
histoire chaque fois que le petit monde
politico médiatique veut vous dissuader
de voter pour un candidat du rupture il
vous raconte qu'il est inhumain il vous
explique qu'il n'est pas crédible eux
qui ont tout raté depuis 40
ans ils prétendent qu'il est d'extrême
droite populiste
infréquentable ils inventent des
polémiques sur
tout et n'importe quoi
il tente de vous démotiver à coup de
sondage il vous raconte que les
pariadentant qu'ils ont moqué et
diabolisé pendant des années serait un
meilleur choix mais ne soyez pas DUP de
toutes ces manœuvres elles nous ont déjà
coûté très cher par le passé elles nous
ont fait perdre tellement de temps et
combien de temps avant-nous encore
combien de temps avant que la France ne
devienne une France africaine sous
l'effet conjugué de la démographie et de
l'IM
incrôl combien de temps avant que
l'Islam ne soit majoritaire sur notre
terre 2060 disent certaines projections
2060 avant que le peuple historique
français ne devienne minoritaire sur la
terre de ses ancêtres
2060 c'est-à-dire demain vous le
connaîtrez peut-être ma fille et vos
enfants le connaîtront si rien n'est
fait
accepterez-vous que la France connaisse
le drame du
Liban voulez-vous vraiment subir le
destin des Serbes du Kosovo
êtes-vous prêt à souffrir le sort des
chrétiens
d'Orient la partition territoriale a
commencé la sécession culturelle est
engagée alors il ne tient qu'à vous de
choisir un autre destin certains diront
que j'exagère mais regardez autour z
vous regardez vos villes regardez vos
quartiers regardez vos campagnes
regardez les changements spectaculaires
qui se sont opérés sous nos yeux depuis
40 ans demander à nos anciens s'ils
reconnaissent encore le doux pays de
leur
enfance alors je m'adresse à tous les
indécis à tous ceux qui doutent encore
si vous en avez assez des élection dont
le résultat est écrit par avance si vous
en avez assez des vieux partis si vous
espérez dans le remblement si vous rêvez
d'une nouvelle histoire politique il n'y
a qu'un seul choix utile c'est celui qui
dans l'isoloire nous permettra de
relever la tête votez avec votre cœur
votez avec vos trip votez avec pour
celui qui aura le courage de dire et qui
aura le courage de faire votez pour Éric
zebour avec
[Applaudissements]
Eric
oui on va gagner et avec Eric Zemour
nous relèverons la tête devant la
racaille nous relèverons la tête devant
la technocratie européenne devant les
trahisons de nos gouvernants devant les
déconstructions de la gauche morale eux
qui nous ont privé si longtemps de la
fierté d'être Français qui nous ont
donné des leçons sur tout alors qu'ils
se sont trompés sur tout
il faut le rappeler incessamment ce sont
les gens comme Eric et tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui l'accompagnent qui avont
tout
anticipé qui a alerté sur les dangers de
l'immigration incontrôlé quand il commun
à la fable du multiculturalisme c'est
nous qui n'a cessé de rappeler que
l'histoire était tragique quand il
dépessa notre outil de défense c'est
nous qui a défendu la nécessité de
l'indépendance énergétique et
alimentaire dans la isation quand il
signait les traités de libre échange
c'est nous qui n'a cessé de rappeler
l'importance de l'industrie le rôle
irremplaçable de la nation quand il
courait derrière le fédéralisme
européen qui en appelait à une
diplomatie d'équilibre dans un monde
multipolaire quand il plaidait pour
l'envoi de troupe en Irak en Syrie en
Libye c'est nous c'est nous qui avons
fait si souvent les bons diagnostics
quand ils étaient aveuglés et qu'ils le
sont encore par leurs intérêts et par
leur idéologie il est donc temps que
nous gouvernions maintenant et c'est à
vous d'en décider maintenant rendez-vous
le 10 avril prochain pour écrire une
nouvelle page de l'histoire de France
vivent les Français et vive la
France
voilà donc on voit les clips de campagne
de Éric Zemour qui est en train de
défiler donc sur à la fois la plateforme
parce que c'est peut-être ça aussi l'une
des leçons de l'après-midi c'est qu'il y
a
quasiment autant de monde peut-être sur
le compte Youtube de Éric Zemour que sur
place que sur place euh peut-être un
commentaire sur ce qu'on vient sur ce
qu'on vient d'entendre donc la prise de
parole de Marion maréchal qui
euh évidemment je dirais joue sa
partition qu'elle joue évidemment très
bien je suis comment dire un peu étonné
je dois le dire et je ne suis pas le
seul euh à l'avoir rallé Éric Zemmour
euh à ce moment-là de la campagne euh il
eut été me semble-t-il plus cohéent
qu'elle le fit soit dès le début soit
qu'elle attende dans le fond la fin de
la guerre Marine Le Pen ERC Zemmour pour
ensuite tenter de recoller les morceaux
c'est-à-dire que là en ayant pris parti
pour éc Zemour contre sa tante et bien
elle ne peut plus jouer le rôle de
réconciliatrice parce que
incontestablement sauf à ce que l'un des
deux ne gagne la présidentielle ce sont
deux forces politiques qui vont
continuer à exister et qui et bien ne
vont pas se siphonner entièrement l'une
l'autre immédiatement et donc il y aura
une nécessité de réorganisation elle
aurait pu jouer ce rôle mais il est
vraisemblable que d'un côté je dirais le
la mal traitance qu'elle et ses amis ont
peut-être subi au rassemblement national
et de l'autre côté le fait que ses amis
ne pourraient obtenir de circonscription
législative que si elle-même ne venait
soutenir explicitement hric Zemour ça
peut expliquer qu'elle ait fait ce choix
de de de rejoindre HC Zemour à ce
moment-là de de la campagne
présidentielle mais honnêtement tous
ceux qui étaient de la tendance Marion
maréchal avait déjà l'intention de voter
pour Éric Zemour et donc je ne pense pas
que son ralliment est fait énormément de
de déplacement de voix euh en tout cas
euh sa prestation a été saluée en tout
cas notamment de dans le chat euh je
voudrais revenir rapidement alors que
Éric Zemour donc doit prendre la parole
d'une minute à l'autre maintenant sur la
scène du trocalero
euh la question du vote caché est-ce
qu'il y a un vote caché en faveur de euh
Éric Zemour ce matin dans le Journal du
Dimanche la politologue
euh qui dirige sciencep Saint-Germain
enly euh nous dit que euh Cécile
braconnier elle dit que le contexte fait
qu'il est plus facile de dire qu'on va
voter Zemour Le Pen et donc le vote
caché a des chances d'être plus faible
on rappelle peut-être la définition en
politologie de ce qu'est le vote caché
c'est-à-dire tous ceux qui euh je dirais
ont l'intention délibérer de voter pour
un candidat mais ne le font pas mais ne
le déclare pas lorsqu'ils sont
interrogés par les instituts de sondage
et donc il y a un décalage entre le
résultat réel et je dirais ce qui est
euh apparaît dans les résultats bruts
des instituts de sondage le vote
communiste à la fin après la guerre le
vote Front national dans les années
80890 exactement lorsque c'était
infamant de déclarer qu'on votait pour
pour le Front national euh le le vote
caché pour Eric Zemmour il n'est
acceptable je dirais enfin il est
envisageable que dans la mesure où euh
il n'y a pas de possibilité pour les
Institutes de sondage de redresser les
résultats bruts voilà en revanche que il
soit honteux de voter pour éc Zemour
alors que c'est quelqu'un qui a été dans
les médias mainstream je je je j'avoue
que c'est un concept qui m'échappe un
tout petit peu et donc par conséquent je
partage cette opinion qu'il n'y a
vraisemblablement pas de vote caché cela
dit euh il peut très bien y avoir un
décalage ça nous l'avons dit mais je
voudrais rappeler aux téléspectateurs
une chose ce qui compte beaucoup plus
que le résultat en pourcentage au jour
le jour ce sont les tendances lorsque
Jean-Marie Le Pen est arrivé au 2uxème
tour à la présidentielle en 2002 il
était sur une courbe ascendante et jpin
sur une courbe descendante et dans la
dernière semaine les courbes se sont
croisées là je constate que tous les
institut de sondage pensent plutôt que
Éric Zemour est sur une courbe
descendante et pas une courbe ascendante
j'en suis au regret pour ceux qui le
soutiennent mais enfin voilà cela dit il
peut parfaitement y avoir effectivement
un décalage de quelques points entre ce
qui est aujourd'hui donné dans les
Institutes de sondage et c'est le
résultat réel mais je crois qu'il y a et
d'ailleurs les orateurs plusieurs
orateurs l'ont dit euh aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de de de d'électeurs de
la droite nationale qui ont décidé de
faire ce qu'on appelle le vote utile en
se disant la présence d'éc Zemour et de
Marine Le Pen risque je voulais signir
votre phraseou risque de faire que l'un
des deux n'y soit pas ou que même aucun
des deux n'y soit et donc il vaut mieux
voter pour celui qui est en tête et
c'est pour l'instant Marine Le Pen ERC
Zemour va vient d'arriver sur le parvis
des Droits de l'Homme place du Trocadero
euh
mes chers amis
quelle joie quel
bonheur quelle
foule quel
[Musique]
ciel quelle
[Applaudissements]
espérance
nous
voici vous êtes
100000 100000 français qui ne reculent
devant
rien 100000 français qui sont fiers de
leur
pays 100000 français qui veulent écrire
l'histoire vous êtes 000 réunis sous le
ciel bleu de
Paris vous êtes venu de toutes les
villes et de tous les villages de
France je
sais je sais que certains sont même
venus de l'outrem et de
l'étranger je sais que des milliers de
policiers de militaires de gendarmes
venu en civil des quatre coins de France
oui je veux que nous leur rendions
hommage mes chers amis vous êtes 100000
au Trocadero et vous êtes des millions
partout en France en métropole et dans
nos outr-merers et à l'étranger à nous
suivre aujourd'hui parce qu'au fond de
vous vous sentez que c'est ici que
s'écrit l'histoire
mes chers
amis mes chers amis il pensait que vous
ne viendriez
pas
[Applaudissements]
il il pensait que vous étiez résigné
et vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
là il voulait vous dire que le scénario
qu'ils avaient préparé depuis 5 ans
était en train de s'accomplir mais vous
êtes
là il ne vous connaissent pas ils ne
connaissent pas l'insolence de notre
peuple la liberté des Français leur
volonté d'écrire l'histoire
il disait que je ne serais pas
candidat il disait
que il disait que je ne dépasserai pas 3
% que je n'aurais pas mes parinages et
que N et nous n
de
militant ils
ont est
[Applaudissements]
oui
ils ont ils ont tout dit et ils se sont
trompés sur
tout vous êtes en train de faire de ce
rassemblement du Trocadero la plus
grande démonstration de force de cette
campagne
oui oui c'est un signe c'est un signal
c'est un sondage grandeur
nature
un avantgoût un avantgoût de la surprise
à
venir vous êtes là vous êtes là et le
printemps est là et le soleil est là
l'espérance est là nous
voici
j'ai j'ai
choisi j'ai choisi le Trocadero pour
venir laver les affrons de la droite les
affronts du peuple qui a le sentiment
légitime qu'on lui a trop longtemps volé
son vote j'ai choisi le
Trocadero cette place qui symbolise
d'abord la France qui se relève après la
défaite de Sedan avec la construction de
la Tour Effel j'ai choisi le Trocadero
en pensant au maréchal Foche sublime
vainqueur de la terrible guerre de 141
qui nous regarde du haut de St cet
après-midi j'ai choisi j'ai choisi le
Trocadero en pensant au général de
Gaulle qui fit ici sur cette place un
grand discours en
1944 quelques jours à peine après avoir
décendu les Champs-Élysées dans Paris
libéré j'ai choisi le
trocadéo car vous comme moi nous n'en
pouvons plus de la division des
patriotes en plusieurs camps cette
division qui est la cause profonde de
nos défaites alors je le dis aujourd'hui
j'aurais besoin de tout le monde avec
mon équipe j'aurais besoin des Gaulistes
j'aurais besoin des souverainistes
j'aurais besoin de toutes les familles
de la droite et de tous les
patriotes
j'ai j'ai des amis aux républicains et
je les accueillerai j'ai des amis au
rassemblement national ils auront toutes
leur place à mes côtés oui j'aurais
besoin d'éicti
applaudissez-le
oui
[Applaudissements]
oui oui j'aurais besoin de François
xadiier
bam de
[Musique]
laurentquier j'auris besoin
[Applaudissements]
de
car c'est l'idée que je me fais de
l'Union des droites car c'est l'idée que
je me fais de la France car c'est grâce
à cette union que nous sommes les seuls
à pouvoir créer la surprise au second
tour face à Emmanuel
Macron mes chers amis aujourd'hui au
Trocadero je suis venu vous livrer un
secret nous sommes les seuls à être de
droite dans cette
campagne nous sommes nous sommes les
seuls héritiers d'une droite qui aime la
France le peuple le travail l'ordre et
l'identité c'est c'est la droite qui
était au RPR la droite de Charles pascoy
la droite de Philippe ségin oui je suis
le seul candidat de droite de cette
[Musique]
élection
regardez-les Valérie pécr est une
centriste
c'est une une centriste déjà prête à
voter Emmanuel
Macron
marine Marine Le Pen est une socialiste
en économie qui ne veut plus prendre
aucun risque de déplaire aux médias sur
les sujets
régaliens quant à Emmanuel
[Musique]
Macron
quant à Emmanuel Macron il a passé 10
ans au pouvoir depuis François Hollande
et il ne sait toujours pas de quel bord
il
est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ils vous disent
que l'élection est déjà jouée qu'on ne
change pas un capitaine dans la tempête
alors qu'il est justement responsable
des tempêtes dans notre
pays ils vous disent ils vous disent que
Marine Le Pen est le vote utile alors
qu'elle n'est utile qu'à la victoire
d'Emmanuel
Macron ils vous disent que les sondages
disent la vérité alors qu'ils se sont
toujours
trompés ils vous
disent
ils vous disent tout et le contraire de
tout et vous ne les croyez plus et vous
avez raison de ne plus les
croire regardez-vous vous êtes là perte
de vue vous êtes les plus nombreux de
cette campagne et vous n'avez pas peur
vous êtes fiers d'être
là
nousez n'ayez pas peur de vos
[Applaudissements]
convictions oui n'ayez pas peur de vos
convictions ce que vous pensez vous
n'êtes pas les seuls à le penser une
majorité de Français le pens nos idées
ne sont pas cvantes sont les
journalistes qui disent qu'elles sont
clivantes elles sont consensuelles
partout en France vous êtes la France
silencieuse regardez-vous regardez
autour de vous je suis venu au Trocadero
pour parler au peuple français tout
entier je suis venu au Trocadero pour
remercier la France ce pays qui m'a tout
donné qui a accueilli ma famille qui m'a
offert sa culture on vous aime on vous
aime on vous aime on vous aime on vous
aime on vous aime moi aussi
[Applaudissements]
oui oui ce pays qui a permis au petits
juif berbère que je suis de me retrouver
sur l'une des plus belles places du
monde devant vous
aujourd'hui quelle quelle émotion mes
chers
amis quelle émotion me suberge en vous
regardant comment comment ne pas penser
à mes parents j'espère du fond du cœur
qu'ils sont fiers de moi de là où ils
[Applaudissements]
sont
rien
[Applaudissements]
rien rien ne me destinait à me retrouver
devant vous aujourd'hui vous le savez je
viens d'en bas vous m'avez connu il y a
bien longtemps je menais une vie risquée
mais j'étais heureux pourtant une
inquiétude me taraudait et venait gâcher
mon bonheur j'avais le sentiment de
comprendre ce qui allait arriver à notre
peuple et d'être impuissant alors j'ai
décidé de me présenter devant vous de
mettre mon destin entre vos mains pour
le salut de la
[Applaudissements]
France non merci à
vous à ceux à ceux qui nous
regardent on va gag on va gag on va gag
on
[Applaudissements]
va à ceux à ceux qui nous regarde pour
la première fois je dis vous avez
peut-être des a prioris sur moi vous
avez entendu bien des choses j'ai
peut-être moi-même dit des choses qui
vous ont déplu j'ai peut-être eu parfois
qui vous a
étonné
profitons profitons de ce moment pour
vous dire qui je suis d'abord je ne suis
pas un politicien professionnel les
journalistes pensent que c'est ma
faiblesse le peuple pense que c'est ma
force parce que je n'ai pas passé ma vie
à trahir mes promesses à suivre la mode
pour monter d'un % dans les sondages
je n'ai pas passé ma vie à intriguer
pour obtenir un poste au gouvernement je
n'ai pas passé ma vie à vivre d'argent
publicque ma vie je l'ai passé à vous
défendre j'ai passé ma vie à dire la
vérité et à en payer le
prix hier
[Applaudissements]
soir
hier soir je demandais à un ami si tu
n'avais qu'une seule raison de voter
pour moi laquelle
choisirais-tu il m'a répondu je vote
pour toi parce que tu dis la vérité et
que le plus grand ennemi de la politique
c'est le
mensonge cet ami VO juste nous sommes le
vote de la véré la vérité difficile à
dire la vérité difficile à entendre la
vérité difficile à admettre mais la
vérité rien que la vérité toute la
vérité pendant cette
[Applaudissements]
campagne pendant pendant cette campagne
je ne vous cache pas qu'il est arrivé
que pendant cette
campagne pendant cette campagne je vous
avoue qu'il est arrivé que certains de
mes proches me disent tu ne devrais pas
dire ça ça ne va pas plaire je leur ai
systématiquement répondu je le dirai
parce que c'est vrai et parce que je le
pense et ça plaira parce que la vérité
plaît au peuple français
vous le savez vous le savez mes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
amis vous le savez mes amis si j'avais
passer ma vie à dire ce que les gens
avaient envie d'entendre je ne sera pas
devant vous
aujourd'hui fait confiance nous sommes
le vote de la vérité et nous sommes le
vote vital parce que dire la vérité
c'est être libre grand
debout mettre notre bulletin dans l'urne
dans de semaines c'est dire la vérité
c'est faire gagner la vérité et quand la
vérité gagne c'est la France qui est
victorieuse je
suis je suis venu
vous par de la France mes chers amis
j'ai fait plus de 50 discours depuis le
début de cette campagne j'en ai fait
beaucoup pour aborder mon programme pour
détailler mes mesures et j'en ai fait
quelquesuns pour parler de la
[Applaudissements]
France
et et à la fin et à la fin de cela vous
êtes venus me voir pour me dire merci
d'avoir parlé de nous
oui quand on parle de la France vous les
Français vous vous sentez concernés
l'avenir de votre pays et celui de votre
famille sont indissociables pour vous
vous avez bien compris que dans cette
élection je suis le seul candidat qui a
à la fois le souci de la fin du mois et
le souci de la fin de la
France car mes amis vous le savez mieux
que quiconque la crainte de la fin de la
France n'est pas une crainte abstraite
ce n'est pas un truc d'intellot ce n'est
pas une lubie nostalgique la crainte de
la fin de la France c'est le malheur
indéfinissable de se sentir étranger
dans son propre pays c'est l'angoisse de
vivre dans un pays violent c'est
l'horreur devant les victimes qui se
multiplient
ant une classetique
[Applaudissements]
lâche
alors alors voulez-vous pour voulez-vous
savoir pourquoi je mène ce
combat voulez-vous savoir pourquoi j'ai
accepté de passer ma vie sous protection
policière voulez-vous savoir pourquoi
vous entendez si souvent dire de moi que
je suis dur on dit de moi que je suis
dur parce que les souffrances de mon
peuple m'endurcissent on dit de moi que
je suis dur parce qu'à Nice j'ai
rencontré Patrick
jardin
[Applaudissements]
Patrick
jardin Patrick jardin a perdu sa fille
Nathalie assassiné le soir du Bataclan
je sais qu'il est là aujourd'hui au
Trocadero et je veux que nous lui
rendions
hommage
Patrick Patrick je n'oublierai jamais
ton regard je n'oublierai jamais tes
larmes je n'oublierai jamais ton courage
on dit de moi que je suis dur parce qu'à
Biaritz j'ai rencontré Madame Véronique
monguillaau on a enlevé à cette femme
son mari qui était chauffeur de bus à
Bayonne laissé pour mort par une bande
de racaille parce qu'il avait osé leur
demander leur titre de trans
[Applaudissements]
madame madame c'est à votre mari que je
pense madame c'est à votre mari que je
pense quand on insulte des milliers de
français quand ces insultes deviennent
des coups quand ces coups deviennent
mortels madame mon guillaot je
n'oublierai jamais votre douceur et
votre dignité dans
l'épreuve
certains certains s'indignent de ma
fermeté ce qui m'indigne moi ce ne sont
pas les mots ou les concepts ce sont les
drames quotidiens que vous subissez ce
qui m'indigne moi c'est qu'on ne rendra
jamais la paix à Eveline Rebert maman de
Julien massacré devant les yeux de son
enfant à Roman
Surer
ce ce qui ce
[Applaudissements]
qui ce qui ce qui m'indigne moi qu'on ne
consolera jamais les enfants de Sarah
Alimi ou de Mir knol on ne rendra jamais
justice à tous ceux que l'État n'a pas
su protéger ce qui me révolte moi c'est
ce jeune homme qui a honte parce qu'en
rentrant chez lui porte de Vand son
vieux père s'est fait agresser et qu'il
a baissé les yeux devant les racailles
ce qui me révolte depuis trop longtemps
c'est la
résignation la résignation des
politiciens la résign du gouvernement
qui nous explique qu'on ne peut plus
rien faire qu'il faut s'habituer que
c'est une
fatalité
non non mes amis il n'y a pas de
fatalité vous pensez que c'est vous qui
devez avoir honte mais non c'est l'État
qui devrait avoir honte je suis là je
suis là pour lutter contre la fatalité
chacun
ass chacun est venu sur cette esplanade
avec ses espoirs avec ses inquiétudes
avec ses attentes je veux dire à chacun
d'entre vous à quel point je vous
comprends à quel point c'est pour vous
que je me bats alors faisons ensemble un
serment mes chers amis que nous nous
battrons ensemble pour les 14 prochains
jours comme pour les C prochaines années
et pour le restant de nos
jours oui j'en fais le serment je me
battrai pour la reconquête de notre
identité je me battrai pour la
reconquête de notre prospérité pour la
reconquête de notre puissance de notre
sérénité de notre
pays je suis je suis venu au Trocadero
parler à tous les Français et je veux
m'adresser d'abord à la jeunesse de
France
jeunes
Français jeunes Français soyez à la
hauteur de vos anciens car sur vos frêes
épaules repose un immense héritage
l'héritage de ceux qui se sont battus
pour que la France reste la France
jeunesse française pense à ce lycéen du
lycée Buffon il s'appelle Lucien le
gros il s'appelle Lucien le
gr il a 15 ans il va se faire fusiller
dans une heure sa dernière lettre est
pour ses
parents mes parents chériis mon frère
chéri je vais être fusillé à 11h avec
mes camarades nous allons mourir le
sourire aux lèvres car c'est pour le
plus bel
idéal j'ai le sentiment à 7ette heure
d'avoir une vie complète nous dit Lucien
alors qu'il n'a que 15 ans et il ajoute
je meurs pour la France donc je ne
regrette rien pendant ces 4 mois j'ai
longuement
médité mon examen de conscience est
positif je suis en tout point satisfait
je vous ser une dernière fois sur mon
cœur
Lucien
oui jeunesse française souviens-toi des
mots du général de Gaulle quand les
premiers résistants arrivent à
[Applaudissements]
Londres
vienent jusque dans nos bras etgorger
nos fils et nos compagnes aux
armes
citoyens formez vos
bataillons
marchons
marchons qu'un
sint abreenons
oui mes amis
écoutez écoutez les mots du général de
Gaulle quand les premiers résistants
arrivent à Londres je ne vous
féliciterai pas d'être venu vous avez
fait votre devoir quand la France
agonise ses enfants se doivent de la
sauver
nous nous ne comparons pas nous ne nous
comparons pas à ombres gigantesques mais
nous savons qu'elle pèse sur nos épaules
ici au Trocadero une jeunesse
sélevée une génération qui refuse de se
soumettre vous savez que vous n'avez pas
le droit d'abandonner le pays pour
lequel ces géants ont été prêts à
mourir vous
n'avez vous n'avez que la France pour
vous défendre et la France n'a que vous
pour la
mes chers amis ici aujourd'hui au
Trocadero nous ne faisons que notre
devoir les politiciens vous parle de
vote utile nous nous sommes le vote
vital c'est ce qu'ils ne comprennent pas
c'est le devoir qui guide nos pas nous
ne nous battons pas pour nous-mêmes nous
nous battons pour nos enfants nous nous
battons pour nos petits enfants alors
aujourd'hui au
je suis venu parler à nos aînés vous
avez connu la vie dans le plus beau pays
du monde vous avez connu l'école de
l'exigence de l'autorité de l'excellence
vous avez connu la courtoisie dans la
rue la galanterie et le respect vous
avez connu la fierté d'être français
vous avez travailler dur et avec
optimisme vous avez fait des enfants et
vous avez cru en l'avenir vous ne
reconnaissez plus le pays dans lequel
vous avez vécu le pays que vous avez
aimé le pays que vous avez construit
vous ne comprenez pas ce qui vous a
échappé vous ne vouliez pas créer ce
chaos oh je ne parle pas seulement
d'immigration ou de sécurité je parle de
notre économie je parle de votre pouvoir
d'achat je parle de vos retraites je
parle du niveau scolaire je parle de
notre système de santé du déclin de
notre armée et de notre industrie je
sais
je sais que vous êtes inquiet pour vos
enfants et vos
petits-enfants non vous n'êtes pas
satisfait vous n'êtes pas satisfait à la
fin du compte car vous auriez aimé
pouvoir transmettre à votre descendance
un monde aussi beau que celui dans
lequel vous avez vécu alors je vous le
dis il ne tient qu'à vous d'offrir à vos
enfants le pays que vous avez connu
vous-même vous avez le pouvoir de faire
basculer cette élection vous avez le
pouvoir de choisir le candidat qui vous
dit oui vous avez raison d'avoir peur je
comprends votre nostalgie mais il n'y a
pas de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fatalité
choisissez choisissez le candidat qui
vous dit je veux que la France
redevienne la France je veux que votre
génération puisse léguer aux suivantes
une nation dont vous n'ayez pas honte je
veux que vous ayez le sentiment d'avoir
travaillé dur pour d'autres résultats
que la colère et la peur je veux que
vous vous sentiez en sécurité chez vous
dans votre pays et que vos vieux jours
soient des jours tranquilles confortable
consacré à vos familles à vos passions
sans angoisse ni désespoir alors alors
je vous propose de redevenir jeune je
vous propose de retrouver l'optimisme de
vos 20 ans je vous propose de vous lever
pour vos petits enfants ils compte sur
vous je vous propose de remettre la
France en ordre comme vos parents l'ont
fait après la guerre je vous y aiderai
je me battrai pour vous je vous donnerai
la force quand vous n'en aurez plus je
vous aiderai avece notre jeunesse je
vous aiderai avec tous nos travailleurs
oui aujourd'hui au Trocadero je suis
aussi venu parler à la France du travail
à la France qui se lève tôt je suis venu
dire à nos employés à nos ouvriers à nos
agriculteurs à nos fonctionnaires à nos
pêcheurs à nos artisans la France se
relèvera grâce à vous grâce à votre
travail moi je vous
[Musique]
aiderai
je je ferai un état qui cessera enfin
d'être dur avec vous quand il est si
faible avec ceux qui ne travaillent pas
j'en finirai avec ces réglementations
envahissantes je baisserai les impôts
comme jamais aucun président avant moi
ne l'avait
fait vous l'avez compris je veux taxer
moins pour gagner plus trop d'impôts
trop de charges trop de taxes trop c'est
trop il est tellement facile pour nos
politiciens de dépenser votre argent
imaginez que dans la France d'Emmanuel
Macron les Français travaillent pour
l'État jusqu'au 14 juillet vous devez
attendre le milieu de l'année pour
pouvoir garder pour vous et votre
famille ce que vous avez gagné avec
votre travail je veux moins d'impôts
pour nos travailleurs moins d'impôts
pour nos retraités pour nos veufs et nos
veuves moins d'impôts pour nos familles
alors vous retrouverez votre pouvoir
d'achat alors le travail payera enfin
vos efforts porteraient enfin leurs
fruits et vous serez de nouveau
heureux je suis venu parler aux chefs
d'entreprise aux commerçants aux
artisans aux indépendants vous êtes des
millions dans notre pays mais vous vous
sentez seul seul au milieu de nulle part
seul contre tous car vous partez de
presque rien d'un rêve d'un désir de
vous exprimer et de réussir et dès le
début vous savez que personne ne va vous
aider vous acceptez ce risque vous allez
au devant du danger vous ne pouvez
compter que sur votre propre volonté
vous croyez en la vie vous croyez en
vous-même mais vous allez bientôt
devenir une cible pour le système
français les technocrates français ne
s'intéressent pas à vous si on vous met
en faillite personne ne le saura car
vous ne manifestez pas vous ne cassez
pas vous ne faites pas grève vous n'avez
pas le temps de faire autre chose que
travailler alors voilà notre héros si
discret traqué par le fisque quiétouffe
d'impôt et de taxes traqué par les
règlement et la paperasse vous voilà
surveillé et bientôt ruiné trop c'est
trop je veux je veux
[Applaudissements]
je veux vous libérer je veux libérer le
travail le mérite et l'effort je veux un
état qui soit enfin bienveillant avec
vous car j'aime l'État qui protège les
Français pas celui qui les met en danger
j'aime l'État qui fait régner l'ordre
pas celui qui traque les honnêtes gens
j'aime l'État qui fait régner la justice
pas celui qui décide quels commerces
sont essentiels et quels ne le selont
pas j'aime l'État qui fait régner la
paix pas celui qui regarde les casseurs
saccager les vitrines et les squaturs
s'installer où ils
veulent je veux un état qui respecte
votre pouvoir d'achat et qui comprend
enfin que ce pouvoir d'achat c'est ce
qui reste quand vous avez fini de payer
vos impôts et toutes vos charges je veux
un état qui a conscience qu' 1 € dépensé
c'est 1 € d'impôt prélevé et qu'un €
gaspillé c'est 1 € volé je veux un état
qui a peur quand il prélève 1 € de plus
parce que c'est peut-être l'euro de trop
parce que c'est peut-être la somme qui
va vous manquer pour subvenir à vos
besoins je veux un état qui ne dilapide
pas votre argent dans des dépens F de
bureaucratie et de cabinet de
[Musique]
conseil je veux un état qui réserve la
solidarité
nationale je veux un état qui réserve la
solidarité nationale aux Français je
veux un état qui ne distingu pas les
Français selon leur origine leur
religion ou leur couleur de peau et et
et c'est un point important et c'est un
point important car on a souvent menti
sur mes intentions on a souvent jouer
sur les peurs avec mes propos alors
aujourd'hui au Trocadero je veux parler
directement à nos compatriotes de
confession musulmane car les
journalistes et les politiciens vous
désinformment et vous mentent ils vous
font croire que je veux vous empêcher de
pratiquer votre religion c'est faux je
connais l'islam mieux qu'aucun de mes
concurrents je connais l'islam comme
vous vous êtes issu d'une culture que je
connais bien car mes parents mes
grands-parents mes ancêtres sont nés en
Algérie vous venez d'une culture dans
laquelle la franchise compte autant que
la parole donnée alors je sais que vous
attendez qu'on vous parle sincèrement
pas comme tous les autres hypocrites qui
n'osent jamais vous dire vraiment ce
qu'ils pensent alors je ne me cache
et je vous le dis il y a un problème
avec l'expansion de l'Islam aujourd'hui
en France il y a un problème car nos
politiciens ont reculé car ils ont voulu
que la France fasse des accommodements
raisonnables avec l'Islam au lieu de
demander aux musulmans de faire des
accommandements raisonnables avec la
France je
vais je vais vous dire de quoi je parle
et
je donner la pratique de votre religion
je respecte toutes les religions et tous
les croyants rien ne vous empêche d'être
vrai français et de vivre votre religion
dans le respect des lois et dans la
discrétion le
choix le choix que je vous propose c'est
d'embrasser la culture française c'est
d'embrasser une langue notre histoire
nos meurs notre art de vivre je veux
croire que c'est possible beaucoup de
compatriotes musulmans ont déjà fait le
choix de l'assimilation et cux je le
répète sont nos
frères en
revanche en revanche si vous n'aimez pas
la France si vous n'aimez pas notre
peuple notre culture notre art de vivre
et et que et que vous ne souhaitez pas
français et
bien et bien et bien c'est votre et bien
et bien c'est votre droit mais
assumez-le je suis honnête avec vous
soyez-le avec la France ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas à la France de s'adapter à
votre culture mais à vous de faire vutre
la culture
française
je je suis le
seul
je je suis le seul à vous dire ces
vérités les autres renoncent certains me
disent vous ne pouvez pas demander au
musulmans le même effort que celui que
votre famille a fait mais quel
mépris et
pourquoi pourquoi les juifs les
Espagnols les Italiens les Libanais les
Arméniens les Portugais les Polonais les
Asiatiques saurais-tu le faire ce que
les musulmans ne pourraient pas faire
moi moi je ne vous méprise pas je ne
vous exclu pas du modèle français comme
tous les autres le font je vous parle
d'égal à égal et droit dans les yeux je
vous tends la main ne vous laissez pas
flatter par ceux qui vous disent que
vous n'avez pas besoin de devenir comme
eux car vous n'êtes pas capable de
devenir comme eux cela ne s'appelle pas
de la tolérance cela s'appelle du mépris
je veux vous dire autre
chose je veux je veux vous dire autre
chose quand vous vivez dans des banlieux
je ne veux plus de ce modèle qui
souhaite seulement qu'on ne vous entende
plus qui ferme les yeux sur le trafic de
drogue pour acheter la paix ce n'est pas
un idéal pour nous ce n'est pas un idéal
pour vous combien de drames combien de
balles perdues combien d'enfants
sacrifiés combien de mères désespéré
voilà ce que veut la gauche pour vous
elle se fiche que des cités entières
soit devenu des enclaves étrangères elle
vous veut seulement loin de ces beaux
quartiers
nous nous nous tenons à chaque
parcelle nous
nous nous nous tenons à chaque parcelle
de notre territoire et à chacun de nos
enfants alors je viens vous demander de
faire l'effort que nous sommes si
nombreux à avoir fait je viens vous
demander de ne pas exacerber les
fractures les Français ne veulent pas de
violence sur leur territoire les
Français sont généreux ils demandent
seul
lese
vous vous vivez dans le plus beau pays
du monde auprès du peuple le plus
généreux du monde dites-moi dans quel
pays pouvez-vous être accueilli ainsi
dans quel pays l'école est-elle gratuite
la santé gratuite l'université gratuite
dans quel pays au monde pouvez-vous
venir comme moi d'une famille dont les
grands-parents parlaient à peine le Fran
et vous présente à l'élection pour la
présidence de la
[Applaudissements]
République
vous vous devez avoir conscience de
cette chance vous devez vous souvenir
pourquoi vos parents ont fu leur pays
ils ont fui la corruption la violence la
dictature et la pression trop forte de
l'islam ne reproduisez pas ici ce que
vos parents ont fui émancipez-vous de la
tutelle de vos pays d'origine accueillez
enfin la France dans votre
cœur
alors alors à tous les Français je suis
ven dire au trader vouszir conscience de
la grandeur de votre pays un pays de
plus de 1500 ans qui a battu qui a bâti
un modèle de civilisation fondé sur
l'universalité la Concorde l'honnêteté
la liberté des femmes le bien commun le
respect du peuple la
fraternité un modèle fondé sur les
valeurs greco-romaines et chrétiennes
mais qui offre à tous sans distinction
de race ou de religion son modèle sa
généros
c'est bien fait je le dis à tous les
jeunes Français apprenez à aimer nos
paysages apprenez à aimer nos monuments
nos mots notre langue nos
[Applaudissements]
héros
mieux mieux ayez la volonté d'ajouter
votre strophe au long poème français
écoutez romain gar je n'ai pas une
goutte de s français mais la France
coule dans mes veines c'est ça
l'assimilation
l'assimilation l'assimilation c'est rire
devant Louis de funess Jean du jardin ou
de
pardu
c'est pleurer en écoutant c'est pleurer
en écoutant Jacques brê qui nous chante
qu'il est paraît-il des terres brûlées
donnant plus de blé qu'un meilleur avril
et quand vient le soir pour qu'un ciel
flambois le rouge et le noir ne
s'épouse-t-il pas c'est
sémouvoir c'est sémouvoir devant
l'élégance de Brigitte bardau et de
Catherine de neuve c'est vibré en lisant
pegy Pascal Victor
Hugo demain d l'aube à l'heure où
blanchit la campagne partirai
vois-tu je sais que tu m'attends j'irai
par la forêt j'irai par la montagne je
ne puis demeurer loin de toi plus
longtemps
l'assimilation c'est connaître nos
proverbes freedonner nos chanson aimer
notre gastronomie l'assimilation c'est
s'émouvoir devant les poutre en flamme
de Notre-Dame de Paris c'est marcher
dans les rues de nos villes en admirant
les siècles de travail qui ont rendu nos
bâtises si belles
l'assimilation c'est être un peu gascon
avec cyano un peu alsacien avec les
marchés de Noël un peu provinçal avec le
champ des cigales c'est être un peu
Corse avec les champ des maquis un peu
auvernia un peu ultraarin bass
catalan
[Applaudissements]
c'est c'est aimer la France des neiges
la France des mers des plaines des
forêts des vallons et des collines la
France des tropiques des soleils
couchants et des soleils levants cette
France si diverse mais si unie ma France
ma France c'est la France laborieuse des
bâtisseurs de cathédrale c'est la France
de Jean la jeune bergère qui sonne la
révolte contre l'occupant
anglais ma ma
France ma France c'est celle ma France
c'est celle des vers de Racine qui font
pleurer le roi soleil c'est celle de
Bonaparte qui part de rien et bâti un
empire avec les rêves de ces
soldats ma France
c'est la garde qui meurt mais ne se rend
pas c'est celle des poilus de Verdin qui
défendent jusqu'à la mort le sol sacré
de la
patrie ma France c'est celle qui monte
des mines et descend des collines c'est
celle de Jean Moulin torturé sans lâcher
un seul secret ma
France c'est aussi charlesznavour qui
chante La Bohème et nous parle d'un
temps que les moins de 20 ans ne peuvent
pas
connaître l'assimilation c'est admirer
les personnages de notre histoire c'est
dire nous quand on parle d'un passé qui
ne fut pas le nôtre je dis nous quand je
parle de la Renaissance je dis nous
quand je parle de l'armée de Napoléon
alors qu'à l'époque mes aïeux étaient
sans doute bergers en
Algérie
l'assimilation l'assimilation mes amis
c'est le contraire du racisme un raciste
ne s'inventerait jamais des ancêtres
communs avec celui dont il se prétend
supérieur il ne proposerait pas de
partager sa culture l'assimilation ce
n'est pas le rejet d'une partie de
soi-même c'est un enrichissement inoui
ce n'est pas une soustraction c'est une
multiplication mes chers
compatriotes vous ajouterez t à
l'édifice français par votre propre
mérite et non pas parce que vous avez la
bonne couleur de peau non pas parce que
vous venez d'un quartier plutôt qu'un
autre non pas parce que la gauche a
décidé que vous cochiez les bonnes
cases
maintenant il faut que les Français il
faut que les Français donnent envie
qu'on leur ressemble il faut que les
Français a l'envie de transmettre ce
trésor qui est la France pour cela il
faut des élites qui aiment France une
classe politique qui connaî son histoire
qui l'admire et veut la transmettre
cette volonté je
l'ai pendant 5
[Applaudissements]
ans
pendant pendant 5 ans
je enfant de France soit fier de son
pays refaire des Français c'est mon
objectif et ce sera le rôle de notre
école nous voulons une école qui offre à
aimer les heures glorieuses de notre
histoire les textes sublimes de notre
littérature nous voulons une école qui
repose de nouveau sur le travail
l'effort le mérite nous voulons une
école qui transmet à nouveau des savoirs
qui apprend à lire à écrire à conter pas
une école qui demande à un garçon de 10
ans s'il ne se sent pas plutôt
fille une école une école qui rétablit
la discipline une école où chaque
professeur sera heureux d'enseigner sa
matière de transmettre son savoir
transmettre ce trésor quelle mission
plus merveilleuse oui mes amis nous
voulons refaire des Français nous
voulons redevenir des bâtisseur nous
voulons recréer le génie français nous
voulons renouer avec la prospérité nous
voulons retrouver la
paix
et et pour cela nous aurons besoin de
toute la nation française alors j'en
appelle à tous les patriotes français à
tous ceux qui n'ont pas abandonné la
France j'en appelle à l'amour que vous
avez pour votre pays pour vos enfants et
pour vos petits enfants j'en appelle à
votre patriotisme j'en appelle aux
classes moyennes qui refuseent d'être
remplacer j'en appelle aux
abstentionnistes qui ne croient plus aux
fausses promesses j'en appelle aux
policiers aux gendarmes aux militaires
qui nous protège et qui savent eux que
je dis la
vérité j'en appelle aux travailleurs qui
refusent d'être ruinés aux agriculteurs
au ouvriers aux artisans aux
indépendants aux enseignants aux
professeurs j'en appelle à tous ceux qui
veulent la paix et la tranquillité dans
notre pays j'en appelle à tous ceux qui
refusent la guerre civile j'en appelle à
tous ceux qui veulent un pays puissant à
ceux qui veulent faire primer le mérite
le talent le travail j'en appelle à ces
électeurs des républicains qui en ont
assez de voir leurs idées trahies j'en
appelle à ces électeurs du Front
national qui voi leurs idées végét dans
une opposition stérile depuis trop
longtemps je vous tends la
main
combien combien de temps encore
voulez-vous rester les spectateur du
déclin de votre pays français si vous ne
le faites pas qui le fera
français si ce n'est pas toi qui te bat
qui se
battra je le dis au plus jeunes d'entre
vous vous raconterez cette campagne à
vos enfants je vous le promets vous leur
direz un jour en 2022 un homme s'est
levé j'ai écouté mon cœur et je l'ai
suivi au début personne ne m'a cru ni
les sondeurs ni les médias ils ont tout
fait pour nous décourager et peu à peu
la France a répondu à l'appel nous avons
répondu à la app et nous allons déjouer
tous les
pronostics plus
[Applaudissements]
tard plus
tard je vous le promets nos descendants
diront de nous 2022 ils ont été
clairvoyants ils ont été grands ils ont
cru en eux-mêmes ils ont cru en la
France ils ont été fidèles à leur nation
ils ont été français on dira de nous ils
sortaient d'un quinquena abominable les
politiciens avaient tout fait pour leur
faire croire que cette élection était
jouée d'avance et à la surprise générale
ils ont refusé de se soumettre ils ont
pris leur destin en main ils se sont
levés et ils ont vaincu la fatalité ils
ont entamé la
reconquête on dira de nous en 2022 ils
ont fait mentir les sondages et les
médias armés de leur histoire de leur
tradition de tout ce qui faisait leur
fierté ils ont été les Français libres
de la France Libre 2022 est l'année de
la dernière chance nous ne pouvons pas
baisser les bras nous seuls pouvons en
décider j'ai besoin de vous de votre
optimisme de votre élan de votre pouvoir
de conviction si vous le décidez le 24
24 avril 2022 au soir nous serons de
nouveau ce pays à nul autre pareil qui
s'en orgueillit de n'appartenir à
personne de ne se soumettre à personne
de n'obéir qu'à son propre destin la
voix sera grande ouverte devant nous
nous n'aurons plus qu'à réussir et nous
le ferons parce que nous aurons le
courage et la volonté nous le voulons
tellement nous le voulons depuis si
longtemps alors laissons derrière nous
le doute et le désespoir adieu la
faiblesse et la soumission adieu les
politiciens qui ont conduit notre pays
dans cette situation la reconquête
commence le 10 avril prochain à 20h
l'avenir sera fier de nous nos enfants
et nos petits enfants seront fiers de
nous alors nous avons un devoir et le
temps presse il est minuit moin le qu
soignez mooi dans la reconquête de notre
pays je sais que ceux qui nous regardent
ont en cet instant envie d'être avec
nous vous êtes resplendissant et vous
ranimez la flamme en eux ils vont nous
rejoindre ils vont nous rejoindre parce
que cet après-midi ils ont compris que
nous étions les seuls à les défendre ils
ont compris que seul le devoir et
l'amour de notre pays nous GUID ils vont
nous rejoindre parce qu'ils aiment la
France et quand on parle de la France
c'est de parle dans 2 semaines nous
allons créer la surprise je vous le
promets il nous reste 14 jours 14 jours
c'est une
éternité la majorité des Français vont
entrer dans l'élection ces deux
dernières semaines à nous de jouer pour
les convaincre sur le terrain nous
sommes les plus nombreux partout en
France nous sommes les plus décidés sur
Internet nous sommes les plus puissants
dans nos meetings nous sommes les plus
fervants maintenant nous le vons qui
peut nous arrêter quelle belle et grande
aventure quelle énergie nous allons
déployer dans les de semaines à venir
quelle détermination je sens chez vous
aujourd'hui français nous avons fait en
3 mois ce qu'aucun politicien n'avait
jamais réussi à faire en 15 ans nous
allons faire en 14 jours ce qu'aucun
autre ne pourra faire impossible n'est
pas français nous allons tout donner
dans les 14 prochain jour et je vous
demande de m'aider nous allons mener un
combat dont nous nous souviendrons
encore dans 10 ans dans 20 ans un combat
qui nous fera entrer dans l'histoire et
je vous demande de m'aider ayez
confiance en vous j'ai confiance en Vous
je mènerai le combat à vos
côtés alors alors mes chers amis
faites-vous partie de cette bataille
historique allonsnous
décider
Deric
Zemour plus de 1 heure de
discours plus de 60 minutes Éric Zemour
qui salue la foule
ému devant après la suite de son
discours l'émotion donc du candidat
c'est la Marseillaise on
[Musique]
écoute
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc on vient de entendre les
derniers instants de de ce meeting on va
retourner dès qu'on le peut du Trocadero
retrouver Timothé Delem et Raphaël
Lazreg qui sont sur place dès que les
réseaux permettront de
diffuser leurs interviews leurs
compte-rendu et d'avoir les interviews
et les retours des militants on va y
revenir avec vous vous êtes nombreux à
ré à réagir sur les
réseaux peut-être une première remarque
Guillaume euh Guillaume Bernard
politologue donc maître de conférence de
lcesse et auteur de la guerre à droite
aura bien lieu le mouvement d'extrogir
schz d'clés de brouè
euh il y a une chose c'est que dans la
dernier moment de ce discours d'une
heure il a jeté toutes les forces dans
la bataille oui
euh on a senti au début une certaine
fébrilité en tout cas moi j'ai cru
sentir une certaine fibrilité
parce qu'il sent bien que évidemment ce
meeting était quelque chose d'important
il a buté sur un certain nombre de mots
euh que son prompteur lui défilait lui
défilait devant lui mais au fur et à
mesure de son intervention il a pris de
l'assurance je dirais que la fibre
zémourienne est revenue au Galot et il
faut bien reconnaître que à la fin il a
été non seulement d'une énergie folle
mais extrêmement émouvant moi je je dois
rester neutre je dois rester un
observateur je dirais attentif je dirais
à tous les toutes les forces politiques
mais il faut bien le dire la fin de ce
discours a été extrêmement bien réussi
euh mais peut-être qu'effectivement
c'est euh la force et l'émotion je
dirais de quelqu'un qui se dit que il
est effectivement en difficulté il a à
plusieurs reprises évoqué le fait que
les qu'il fallait faire mentir les
sondages ce qui est possible mais encore
une fois lorsqu'on fait une analyse on
est bien obligé de prendre les
instruments queon a Peire on peut faire
toujours mentir les sondages parce dans
la mesure où les sondages sont une
photographie à une moment donné donc les
sondages qu'on a à l'heure actuelle sont
à la fois la moyenne de tous les
sondages qui ont été faits jusqu'à
présent mais qui sont l'élection si elle
avait lieu au moment où le le le le
sondage a été fait même si on projette
on se projette quand on répond on dit
oui le 10 avril je voterai tel ou tel
mais enfin c'est on est on est c'est je
je voterai pour tel ou tel le 10 avril
mais le 27 mars et donc ça changer exct
et donc il y a deux éléments à prendre
en considération qui pourrai faire
mentir les sondages effectivement c'est
un le fait qu'il y a des marches
d'erreur et de le la la comment dire la
certitude du vote et ça malheureusement
les hommes politiques ne le prennent pas
suffisamment en considération on sait
que pour Éric Zemour pour Mélenchon pour
encore plus Marine Le Pen la certitude
du vote est très forte et beaucoup plus
forte que pour d'autres candidats et
donc évidemment il est possible que les
sondages ment finalement bon donc dans
ce qui est de la forme je dirais que au
final malgré une petite fébrilité à mon
sens au début je dirais le discours est
une réussite je dirais a il a
certainement enthousiasmé les foules
foules qui sont qui est très nombreuse
il a annoncé le chiffre de 100000
personnes présentes alors c'est la
question estil faut y croire et je crois
que c'est crédible c'est peut-être un
peu en dessous mais en tout cas il a
annoncé un un chiffre qui est crédible
par rapport au chiffres qui avait été
annoncé par les fillonistes il y a 5 ans
qui avait annoncé 200000 personnes et
même Bruno rotillot avait parler de
300000 ce qui est évidemment totalement
irréaliste bon en tout cas moi j'y étais
à l'époque il y avait du monde y avait
du monde ah non non mais ça c'est
certain il y avait du monde il y en
avait également
aujourd'hui oui naturellement il y en
avait aussi aujourd'hui comme on l'a dit
une salle une salle pardon une place de
21000 m car environ trois personnes par
TR ou qure personnes par par mètre carré
on peut donc considérer que sur la place
il y a 60 à 70000 personnes il y a des
personnes sur les différentes avenues
disons que il a sans doute un peu
grossier le chiffre mais enfin en tout
cas c'est un énorme meeting c'est
incontestable donc pour ce qui est de la
forme discours et présence militante
c'est réussi est-ce que ça va se
traduire dans les urnes c'est une autre
affaire et puis après il y a le contenu
et est-ce que vous me laissez le temps
d'en parler maintenant on va en reparler
peut-être on va commenter les les images
et on regarde on a également le retour
des images de Timothé d'EM et de Raphael
laszreg Timothé est-ce que vous
m'entendez
oui Vincent je je vous entends très bien
voilà nous sommes donc à nouveau aux
abords de la place du Trocadero la place
qui se situe juste derrière moi vous le
voyez les militants sont en train petit
à petit de quitter la place avec une
musique qui est en train de retentir à
nouveau alors que les pour accompagner
les les militants ce discours d'éc
Zemour qui a duré donc un peu plus d'une
heure un discours assez offensif au
cours de laquelle et bien les militants
ont été chauffés à blanc nous avons pu
accéder vraiment tout devant quasiment à
à la tribune et donc avec des militants
qui étaient assez assez survoltés qui
n'ont pas hésité à couper Éric Zemour
pendant son discours avec des slogans
des slogans de type ici c'est la France
de type on est chez nous plusieurs
marseillaises également ont été entonnés
pendant le discours et on a bien vu vu
que ERC Zemour a a fait l'effort de
laisser les les militants s'exprimer il
a pas hésité à couper ses phrases pour
laisser et bien les slogans monté la
Marseillaise également se mener jusqu'à
son jusqu'à son son terme ERC Zemour qui
a également multiplié les les les les
les séquences de où où il s'adresse
directement au public et où il laisse le
public terminer sa phrase vous savez par
exemple lorsqu'il dit la vraie droite et
que le public répond c'est nous voilà
c'est un une technique de rhtorique
qu'il a utilisé à plusieurs reprises un
fait notable également et vous le vous
en parliez à l'instant sur le plateau
ERC Zemour a revendiqué 100000 personnes
sur place on sait que la place du
Trocadero en temps en temps normal on
estime la capacité à à peu près 50 à
60000 personnes il y a en fait c'est que
effectivement les les rues adjacentes
étaient étaient en tout cas pas
forcément rempli mais il y avait du
monde également dans les rues de là à
dire qu'il y avait 100000 sympathisants
je ne m'y risquerais pas euh ERC Zemour
a probablement comme vous le disiez
Guillaume Bernard gonflé un petit peu le
le chiffre mais en tout cas il faut il
faut le dire il y a vraiment beaucoup de
personnes cet après-midi les militants
qui vous le voyez derrière moi sont en
train maintenant de quitter la place
alors on a dû s'éloigner un petit peu
pour des questions de réseau
malheureusement c'est la raison pour
laquelle là vous avez peut-être
l'impression que c'est un petit peu vide
derrière moi mais nous sommes voilà nous
sommes à à à bien 150 m de de la de la
place et et et les militants qui sont en
train petit à petit de de quitter les
lieux et nous allons essayer maintenant
de d'en chercher un ou deux pour
recueillir leur leurs témoignag à la fin
de ce de ce discours et de ce meeting
merci beaucoup Timothé et effectivement
on vous laisse y aller on va continuer à
de débriefer
effectivement la question des réseaux
est importante parce que on avait eu
exactement le même phénomène il y a 5
ans pour le grand meeting de de François
Fillon où l'équipe de Figaro live a été
avait été obligé d'aller avenue Ron
Point Carré à l'époque euh en contrebas
de la place du
Trocadero parce que il on n'arrivait pas
à faire à à à diffuser en direct et en
réseau c'est intéressant quand même de
voir et c'est ce que disent également
d'autres internautes que il y avait du
monde autour de la place du du TR cadero
donc ce qui en tous les cas rend
crédible une estimation qui va au-delà
des 50 et 60000 personnes qui é entendu
surtout si on y ajoute les personnes qui
étaient en direct sur les les réseaux en
particulier le compte Youtube de d'Éric
Zemour où on est allé même on est monté
à plus de 70000 personnes et également
bien entendu le compte Youtube du de
Figaro live où vous êtes en train
continuer de de commenter vous nous
donnez vos réactions vous nous posez vos
questions on continue on débat on
rebondit pendant une vingtaine de
minutes pendant que on regarde ces
images également de la place du
Trocadero où on voit donc Éric Zemour
encore à la rencontre
des personnes qui étaient présentes à ce
meeting bain de foule euh il y a un
enjeu quand même pour Éric Zemour avant
de de revenir sur le fond c'est et
maintenant il lance la bataille c'est la
bataille c'est la reconquête pour les 15
jours à venir mais pour l'instant est-ce
qu'il y a des meetings qui sont prévus
est-ce qu'il y a des happenings qui sont
prévus comment justement il peut
matérialiser cette cette reconquête
comment il peut
matérialiser cette séquence qui le
sépare des 15 derniers jours attendu que
la semaine prochaine il y a deux autres
meetings les meetings d'Emmanuel Macron
et les meetings de Valéri pcres déjà
Valéri PCR qui avait attendu 18h ce soir
donc à partir dans une demi-heure qui
fera un grand meeting sur zoom qui est
également à retrouver sur le site du
figero alors je crois que Éric Zemour a
voulu faire une démonstration de force
avant que ne commence de demain la
campagne officielle où il va y avoir
pour le coup à partir de demain un
traitement égalitaire de tous les
candidats jusqu'à présent c'était un
traitement dit équitable en fonction du
poids potentiel je dirais des candidats
dans les médias là désormais ça sera un
traitement un traitement égalitaire et
donc il pense peut-être qu'il fallait
marquer un grand coup avant je dirais
que il non pas qu'il ne disparaissent
mais qu'il soit je dirais un parmi les
12 candidats qui ont été désignés par
les parler parrainage ensuite il me
semble que et ça rejoint votre question
on on touche je dirais là à un un yatus
si pour ce qui est de la forme et de la
présence militante c'est une vraie
réussite du point de vue stratégique
j'avoue que je n'ai pas forcément très
bien
compris ce que Éric Zemour avait cherché
à faire parce que au tout début de la
campagne il dit je suis le RPR avec
cette idée que il est une force
politique de droite qui est supposée
s'assume mais et donc qui n'est pas je
dirais prise comme LR puis l'UMP pardon
l'UMP puis LR fagocité par les positions
centristes et avec cette capacité à
prendre des deux côtés des électorats du
côté RN et du côté LR ça il continue
toujours à le dire mais toute une partie
de sa campagne a été à l'évidence faite
pour chercher à démonétiser Marine Le
Pen pour essayer de capter son électorat
or il n'y a pas vraiment réussi et là ce
soir alors que ou cet après-midi plutôt
alors que il a plutôt capitalisé sur
l'ancien électorat Fillon euh il et que
il a fait le reste de sa campagne en
cherchant à siphonner Marine Le Pen tout
en y'y arrivant pas vraiment et bien ce
soir il essaye de il fait un
essentiellement un appel à la droite
fillionis celle qui est déjà dans ses
rangs et il ne va pas chercher
l'électorat RN qui lui manque qu'il n'a
pas c'est-à-dire les catégories
populaires ouvriers et employés et là
j'avoue que stratégiquement ça m'étonne
alors peut-être que ce sera le cas dans
les dans les peut-être que ça sera le
cas dans les jours à venir c'est
possible mais ça me paraît bien tardif
pour le coup on va rejoindre Timothé
dellem qui est à côté de la place du
Trocadero avec une militante Timothé
c'est à vous
oui Vincent avec une militante qui a qui
s'est arrêté alors qu'elle est en train
de de quitter la la place bonjour madame
merci d'être avec nous quelle a été
votre impression générale suite à ce
discours d'Éric Zemour une impression de
de gravité de
solennité d'un d'une personne qui a
endosser le costume de du du président
j'espère vraiment qu'il sera élu je
pensais pas qu'il serait candidat pour
vous dire je suis pas une zémourienne de
la première heure mais il m'a convaincu
j'aime les gens qui disent la vérité qui
est pas
souvent facile à entendre mais qui est
porteuse d'espoir pour pour la France
qui qui vit quand même un certain déclin
il faut le constater donc j'ai trouvé ce
discours en apothéose de toute cette
campagne de de Zemour j'ai suivi les
autres meetings sur sa chaîne Youtube et
là je dois dire qu'il y avait une une
ferveur une c'était merveilleux d'être
au milieu du du peuple parisien de
toutes CSP toute catégorie
socio-pressionnelle confondu c'était un
moment de qui m'a galvanisé et qui me
fait y croire encore sur l'aspect
solennel il y a une scène effectivement
que l'on retiendra peut-être de ce
meeting c'est ERC Zemour qui avance vers
la scène lors du tout début de son
discours c'est quelque chose qu'il
n'avait pas qui n'avait pas été mise en
scène à ce point-là lors des précédents
grands meetings là on a vu Éric Zemmour
s'avancé sur la scène un petit peu à
l'image d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 au
Louvre lorsqu'il a remporté l'électionés
marche et j'ai trouvé que ptier avait
été formidable en chauffeur de Sal alors
juste juste sur cette scène d'Éric zéour
qui qui avance de manière solennelle on
voit qu'il y a une stratégie de de
chercher à endosser le costume
présidentiel est-ce que vous pensez que
ERC Zemour peut faire taire les procès à
ce niveau-là lorsqu'on dit qu'il n'a pas
la carure présidentielle mon dieu il l'a
largement enfin je je veux pas on va pas
parler du du du physique de l'aspect des
gens il a 1000 fois plus la ure qu'un
mystificateur je trouve que nous avons à
la tête de l'État depuis 5 ans voilà il
est il est tout de vérité de conviction
de force n' que des coups à prendre dans
cette campagne il les a pris il les a
assumé et effectivement il marche il va
vers l'avant c'est formidable il n'a pas
reculé devant les les obstacles et les
embûes qui ont été posés sur son moi je
suis pas politiquement correct de penser
comme ça dans mon entourage
professionnel disons et amical où il y a
beaucoup de partisans de Macron je suis
pour la discussion tous les arguments de
zmour sont pesés argumentés détaillés
précisés quand je demande les raisons de
voter Macron je je n'entends rien je
n'entends rien qu'est-ce que vous avez
pensé de de l'ambiance vous me disiez
avantamb on ça été un moment de partage
avecie place milieu de la place jeune
vieux malade pas malade enfin c'était
extraordinaire c'était vraiment le
peuple de France merci beaucoup voilà V
pour cette Inter j donc de cette
militante pro pro éc Zemour on va
essayer peut-être d'aller d'aller
chercher d'autres personnes voilà grande
lectrice du Figaro me confie me confie
madame également merci une excellente
habitude vous féliciter cette dame pour
ses habitudes de consommation média et
j'espère de figero Live également merci
beaucoup merci à elle et merci pour
cette pour cette intervention sonbrra
nous dit Éric Zemour n'est pas gouliste
il veut diminuer la place de de l'État
vrai
faux le problème du golisme c'est qu'en
fait chacun y met à peu près euh ce
qu'il veut euh aujourd'hui disons que le
golisme c'est quand même essentiellement
la question de la souveraineté de la
France dans le cadre de la construction
européenne et dans le cadre des
relations internationales notamment par
exemple la question de l'OTAN parce que
disons-le euh les idées sociales de
Charles de Gaulle qui était pour le coup
très catholique social disons la
participation personne ou quasiment
personne n'en parle donc si vous voulez
sincèrement honnêtement le golisme est
mort alors peut-être pas avec le départ
de De Gaulle en 69 disons avec le départ
de Pompidou la mort le décès de Pompidou
en
74 après tout le monde en a fait à peu
près ce qu'il en voulait repérant une
idée ou une position de Charles de
Gaulle pour essayer je dirais de se
vêtir du du du du costume donc que Keric
Zemour se dit disent goliste dans le
sens où il veut un état régalien et un
état souverainiste ça me paraît légitime
qu'il le disent peut-être une évolution
sur le plan économique Éric Zemour votre
Chevenement en 2002 en tous les cas
c'est ce qu'il dit euh Chevenement et le
partisan d'un État fort même au au plan
au plan social là on a entendu très
clairement le discours d'un candidat en
matière fiscale en particulier on
l'avait déjà entendu dans les
précédentes dans les précédents meetings
notamment le meeting de Lille qu'on
avait commenté ensemble mais en matière
fiscale très clairement c'est un c'est
euh une critique en règle de l'État
bureaucratique et de l'état des cabinets
de consultant et et et de l'État
providence autrement dit là il a parlé à
l'électorat qui est séduit par ses
positions qui est plutôt un électorat
disons bourgeois citadin CSP+ donc
effectivement un discours plutôt de type
libéral encore que c'est un terme là
aussi
très sensible et qui est un terme piégé
parce que ce n'est pas parce que l'on
n'est pas libéral que l'on est forcément
collectiviste parce que le libéralisme
c'est bien des choses et notamment c'est
une philosophie politique globale mais
je crois qu'on ne peut pas dire que Éric
Zemour soit un libéral au sens
philosophique mais que en terme de
fiscalité il est plutôt sur des
positions de type libéral un peu comme
l'été dans le fond Jean-Marie Le Pen
dans les années 80 et le début des
années 90 non il un libéralisme enfin en
tous les casoche
proche de la de la représentation Ronald
ran margaretch ex voilà euh on va
retourner place du Trocadero Timothé
Delem est avec une
militante on va bah justement l'écouter
oui Vincent avec une militante à nouveau
qui vient de de de d'entendre ce
discours d'Éric Zemour bonjour madame
qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé qu'est-ce
qui vous a on imagine que vous avez
plutôt apprécié ce discours de zour
qu'est-ce que vous avez apprécié cet
après-midi alors ce que je trouvveis
intéressant c'est que je crois qu'il
s'adresse vraiment à une droite diverse
donc ça c'est une première chose il se
positionne clairement au deuxème tour il
s'adresse directement à des électeurs du
Front national qui peuvent être déçus du
socialisme et de l'échec du du FN et il
laessit il continue
d'essayer de dire qu'il n'est pas
raciste et cetera moi-même j'ai venu
pour voir qui soutient zimour parce que
pour moi c'est importante et je voulais
voir qui est sa public et je trouvais
que son adresse très franche à les
musulmans de France était intéressante
et inédit là où je trouvais qu'il était
fort s'il a continuuer dans son alignée
de sincérité et de dire je pars droite
euh est-ce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
matières peut-être pas assez pour les
indécis donc je trouve que cette
discours était vraiment adressé à des
personnes qui sont déjà du droite et qui
vont hésiter entre une Macron une PESS
et une zimour avec une vraie tentative
de chercher le FM justement sur ces
personnes qui sont de droite qu'est-ce
qui fait que vous de votre côté vous
penchez pour Éric Zemour plutôt que pour
par exemple Valéri pcrè ou Marine Le Pen
alors je ne suis pas encore décidé pour
moi Marine Le Pen n'est pas du droite
donc pour moi elle est limite une
Mélanchon et j'ai assez peur d'elle bien
que je puisse respecter la personne
ensuite entre le vrai
droite je chercherai quelqu'un qui peu
arriver dans le 2ème tour je cherche
quelqu'un qui peuve rassembler le droite
je suis très à l'écoute comme canadienne
et comme française de choix à cette
notion d'intégration et je trouve que
jusqu'à là l'intégration en France est
très mal fait donc je parle de ma
position je vis dans le 16e j'ai une
entreprise et j'ai beaucoup de
privilèges mais ça ça m'inquiète de voir
qu'on peut pas sélectionner nos
immigrants comme au Canada on n'est pas
capable
d'assimiler et je trouve que c'est vrai
si on demande à une Canadienne de
chanter l'hyne nationale ils le font
avec du plaisir et c'est trop longtemps
que la française est est hésitante mis à
part une match de foot donc je suis à
l'écoute de cette envie nationaliste des
Françaises et qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire maintenant puisque de ce que je
comprends dans votre propos c'est que
pour l'instant votre choix n'est pas
fait qu'est-ce que vous allez faire vous
avez de semaines encore pour décider
pour qui voter lors du premier tour le
10 avril prochain alors mon choix est
difficile parce qu'en fait au fond de
moi je ne suis pas anti-européenne et je
ne suis pas
antiutant en terme de discours concrè où
je peux rejoigner une zimour c'est
l'éducation nationale c'est du grand
n'importe quoi j'étais obligé de mettre
mess dans le privé comme d'autres et et
ça c'est dommage
ensuite pour toute cet idéal de la
France donc je pense qu'on est dans une
moment égalienne où le nationalité
doivent être vu d'une façon positive
donc où j'hésite j'ai besoin de vraiment
voir PCR donc je lui donne de TR jours
pour se soigner de
son de sa maladie et
Macron j'ai énormément de reproche une
autre chose où je trouve que Zemour a
manqué des marqué des points c'est il a
pas parler à les petits entrepreneurs
les artisans les les personnes oubliées
et C côté uno il faut arrêter je suis
100 % d'accord juste si on parle de
Fessenheim qu'on a pu le fermer juste
pour devenir pronucléaire plus tard ou
la raison disait que si on cherchait une
solution environnementale c'était
clairement le nucléaire donc je trouve
que la candidature de Zemour a vu juste
depuis à peu près le début vous disiez
au début de cette interview que vous
êtes venu aussi pour voir un petit peu
quels sont les soutiens d'Éric Zemour
qui sont quels sont les type de
personnes qui le le soutiennent est-ce
que vous avez eu la réponse il y a
quelque chose par exemple qui qui est
assez frappant cet après-midi c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup de jeunes alors les
jeunes m'ont pas surpris je pensais dev
voir
plus de certaines bleu et des visages
blondes on est dans le 16e donc je
pensais qu'il y aurait plus de Bourges
ce qui m'a choqué c'était de voir la
France populaire parce qu'on va toujours
où on a matraqué dans le média que
zimour ne touchait pas cette population
et en fait de voir autant de personnes
qui me semblent pas du tout du quartier
m'a surpris quand vous dites choqué donc
c'est plutôt dans le sens interpellé du
coup j'imagine ça m'a interpellé je
pense que sur ces propositions de
pouvoir d'achat il commence d'être
pertinente une dernière question madame
Éric Zemour a dit qu'il aurait besoin
dit-il de le renvoquer d'Eric sootti ou
encore de Nadine Morano donc il va
chercher les ténors des républicains on
voit la symbolique d'ailleurs de cette
place du Trocadero c'est là où François
Fillon avait fait un grand meeting en
2017 Nicolas Sarkozi en 2012 est-ce que
vous pensez que Eric Zemour a des
chances de réelles chances et bien
d'aller convaincre cette cet électorat
déçu des républicains
ah oui oui je pense que la droite est
assez ils sont impériil il voi très
clairement qu'est-ce qui se passe à les
socialistes et ils sont pas loin d'avoir
le même sort donc je pense qu'
aujourd'hui la droite doivent être
inquiète et doivent être à l'écoute de
quelqu'un qui peuvent les rassembler
merci beaucoup euh madame et voilà
Vincent donc pour cette pour cette
militante qui quitte à l'instant le
discours le meeting d'Erc Zemour
derrière moi je ne sais pas si vous vous
en rendez bien compte l'ambiance est en
train de retomber le discours est
terminé il n'y a plus de musique et la
place continue de se vider petit à
petit remonter vers la place pendant que
nous on débriefe ici euh à la recherche
peut-être d'autres personnalit d'autres
personnes d'autres ah c'était pas
forcément une militante d'ailleurs là
c'était plutôt une personne qui était
venu c'est c'est intéressant d'avoir C
point de vue c'est une personne
d'origine étrangère c'est la deuxième
que Timothé interroge comme ça à la
volée depuis le depuis le début euh et
beaucoup de femmes parce que on sait que
ERC Zemour a de manière globale un
retard dans l'électorat féminin alors là
il y avait effectivement des femmes qui
ont accepté de parler à vis j'aicouvert
euh soit pour montrer leur soutien soit
pour montrer leur intérêt pour Éric
Zemour donc ça effectivement c'est quand
même intéressant si on fait l'analyse
rhtorique Guillaume est-ce que une des
forces d'éc Zemour en tous les cas un
des atouts peut-être qu'il a dans cette
dans cette bataille et dans ces derniers
jours c'est cette thématique qu'il a
esquissé pendant le pendant le discours
euh qui semble-t-il à une résonance
c'est le discours de vérité
oui il est certain que il essaie de
jouer incontestablement la carte de du
non professionnalisme en politique en
disant tous les autres sont des gens qui
par leur longévité dans la vie politique
ont démontré que ils vivent de la
politique ce qui n'est pas mon cas le
seul problème c'est qu'effectivement si
lui n'arrive pas effectivement à aller
jusqu'au bout euh en tout cas s'il
n'arrive déjà pas à aller au 2uxè tour
bah il va devenir en tant que patron de
parti politique un professionnel de la
politique même si j'imagine qu'il n'en
vivra pas et va se poser pour lui
évidemment la question de savoir est-ce
qu'il prend le risque d'aller au
législative en prenant évidemment le
risque de ne pas être élu on imagine
bien que Marine Le Pen réélu à
eninbaaumont et lui pas élu dans une
autre circonscription évidemment ça
fragiliserait reconquête par rapport au
rassemblement national il est certain
que il y a là je dirais la recomposition
de des des forces politiques qui qui est
en train de se jouer et que hormis je le
répète pardon pour cette répétition mais
hormis le cas où Éric Zemour ou Marine
Le Pen gagnerait l'élection
présidentielle si aucun des deux ne la
gagne euh et si évidemment encore plus
aucun des deux n'était au second tour
mais enfin si aucun des deux ne la gagne
il est certain que ces deux partis
continueront à exister et que il faudra
trouver euh une plateforme commune pour
pouvoir rassembler les différents
électorats et puis pu des compromis pour
pouvoir peut-être se répartir les
circonscriptions encore que je n'y crois
pas trop puisque on le sait une partie
une grande partie du financement public
des partis politiques vient du premier
tour des élections législatives et donc
il y a fort à parier qu'il y aura des
candidats Ren et des candidats
reconquête dans les mêmes
circonscriptions ce que l'on verra ce
qui est important de voir
c'est au soir du premier tour quels
seront les appels explicites à voter
j'imagine mal évidemment mour qui ne
serait pas au deuxème tour et qui dirait
qui appellerait à voter Emmanuel Macron
mais ce qu'il appellera explicitement à
voter pour Marine Le Pen ça n'est pas
certain s'il n'est pas au deième tour et
inversement pour Marine Le Pen est ce
qu'elle appellerait explicitement à
voter r zéour si jamais elle-même n'y
était pas et que lui y était on va jeter
un petit coup d'œil sur la place du du
Trocadero avec les images que sont en
train de tourner Raphaël et Timothé
attention accrochez-vous ça bouge un peu
mais c'est comme ça quand on marche et
c'est la spécificité de Figaro live
c'est de vous euh faire vivre et d'être
en immersion dans l'instant euh
effectivement on voit que la place se
vide à la place du Trocadero se vide
avec euh là la possibilité maintenant de
pouvoir tourner depuis euh la place en
tant en tant que tel
euh si on revient au début du discours
et si on revient euh au sens du choix de
cette place du Trocadero on remarquera
on notera que Éric Zemour c'est apesanti
sur ce choix-là euh avec un certain
nombre de j'allais dire d'arrêts au
stand et vous remarquerez c'est pas pour
nous lancer des fleurs mais que il a
d'une certaine manière confirmé ce que
nous-même nous avions dit au début de
cette émission avant même qu'il ne
prenne la parole à savoir que et bien il
est là pour essayer d'incarner cette
droite à qui enfin qui pense qu'on lui a
volé deux élections en 2012 et en 2017
et qu'il est là pour je suis là pour
laver les affront de la droite laver les
affronts et venger d'une certaine
manière ces électeurs là c'est pour ça
que lorsqu'il fait des appels au soutien
on remarquera qu'il fait quand même
essentiellement des appels du pied àr à
des cassiques LR alors que par ailleurs
il a une grande partie de l'élector alr
qui a rejoint qu'il fait beaucoup moins
appel à je dirais des Cass du
rassemblement national alors que là pour
le coup il a moins engrangé d'électeurs
de ce côté-là parce qu'effectivement on
le sait bien il y a une différence
sociologique et professionnelle et
géographique entre les deux électorats
un électorat RN qui est plus populaire
et qui est plus france-périphérique un
électorat LR qui est plus bourgeois et
qui est plus urbain à partir de 18h vous
pourrez suivre en direct le meeting
cette fois-ci sur zoom de Valérie pcres
euh c'est d'ici une dizaine de minutes
on reste avec vous pour l'instant pour
continuer à de débriefer donc ce
rassemblement au Trocadero erriic Zemour
qui revendique 100000 personnes réunies
place du Trocadero avec un discours euh
qui a duré un petit peu plus d'une heure
euh discours euh qui s'est achevé donc
il y a maintenant un peu moins de trois
quarts d'heure François Xavier Bellami
Laurent vquier Moran et aussi Jordan
maraldellaa ce sont les noms qui ont été
cités et Zemour a demandé qu'on les
applaudisse oui bien sûr parce que il se
dit que les électeurs par exemple
d'éicotti lors de la primaire fermée de
LR C dernier par il a pas cité Eric Coti
ceci dit ah si si si si il a cité erti
si si si si il a cité
ericti et même je crois même en premier
en tout cas il pense que cet électorat
là est tout à fait susceptible de voter
pour lui dès le premier tour ou en tout
cas il espère qu'il votera pour lui dès
le premier tour étant donné qu'Eric
sioti avait dit que euh si jamais Eric
Zemour était confronté à Emmanuel Macron
il n'aurait pas de difficulté à voter
pour Éric Zemour face à Macron pour
autant euh je crois que euh euh il sait
aussi une chose qu'il n'a pas évoqué
publiquement à savoir que
euh il y a tout un ensemble de
personnalités alr qui euh dans le fond
se satisferait bien d'un échec singlant
pour Valéri pcrè en se disant qu'ils
pourront ramasser le parti politique KLR
on prononce les noms de Laurent voquier
et d'Eric soti qui
s'associeraiit exactement pour reprendre
pour reprendre le parti et pour pour le
coup essayer de
reyonner du côté de reconquête
l'électorat LR qui est parti chez Éric
Éric Zemour et je crain que pour Éric
Zemour il y ait peut-être des déconvenus
on sait qu'il y a un sénateur alors
qu'il y avait peut-être beaucoup plus je
dirais d'élus nationaux députés et
sénateurs LR qui étaient susceptible de
le rejoindre il y en a eu un qui a eu il
faut bien le dire le très grand courage
de faire ce basculement c'est Sébastien
mand mais pour l'instant il y a quand
même pas énormément de Cassique de ce
parti qui bascule tout simplement parce
qu'ils se disent qu'un échec à la
présidentielle certes c'est évidemment
très ennuyeux mais qu'ils ont toujours
des résultats et des élus locaux et
qu'il pourrai peut-être refaire vivre le
parti politique c'est très ambitieux
c'est très hypothétique parce qu'un
parti politique qui n'est pas à
plusieurs reprises au deème tour de la
présidentielle c'est quand même un parti
en déserrance il y a qu'à voir
aujourd'hui la situation du Parti
socialiste mais il est certain que là il
joue son vatou Éric Zemour et que il est
dans une situation où il a besoin
effectivement de de faire le plus haut
score possible même s'il n'atteint pas
le deuxème tour pour pouvoir être très
largement au-dessus de LR et pour
pouvoir lui finir de siphoner LR avec de
l'autre côté ceux qui partiront chez
chez Emmanuel chez Emmanuel Macron alors
Timothé Delem essaie d'attraper Philippe
Devillier on essaie de on reste
justement en direct le temps que cela
puisse se faire et ben voilà je vois
Philippe dev Villier s'approcher de
Timothé d'EM Timothé vous avez la
parole vous êtes ça va all oui Vincent
avec Philippe de Villier soutient et
bien évidemment d'Éric Zemour Philippe
de viler merci d'être avec nous Éric
Zemour on le disait en plateau a insisté
sur cette symbolique de la place du
Trocadero il a également dit qu'il
aurait besoin d'éicioti de Laurent vé de
Nadine Morano est-ce que la
qualification au second tour pour Erric
Zemour ça passe par
ça je pense que la qualification au
second tour elle va dépendre beaucoup de
la
participation et là on a eu un avantgoût
de la participation
et moi je serai commentateur je serai
journaliste je seraai homme politique
concurrent je m'inquiéteraiis justement
sur cette mobilisation on nous disait
que ça serait une une grande un grand
coup de force pour éc Zemour cet
après-midi est-ce que vous êtes
satisfait alors c'est ce qu'il a appelé
lui-même très justement une
démonstration de force un sondage
grandeur nature peut-être un avantgoût
de de la surprise à venir et en fait
c'était
aussi avait clin d'œil savezouard
Philippe avait dit à la droite Trocadero
avec mépris ben la droite Trocadero elle
était là aujourd'hui sous le grand
soleil et elle a pris sa revanche en
quelque sorte parce que du temps de la
droite Trocadero en
2017 François Fillon a été littéralement
abattu par le parquet national
financier et beaucoup autour de lui se
sont égayés après la soirée du Trocadero
et donc nous on voulait montrer que
cette droite là elle existe plus que
jamais elle est diverse il y a des gens
qui viennent de tous les horizons et
d'ailleurs les figures qui entourent er
Zemmour viennent de tous les horizons et
on voulait montrer surtout
que ce que dit éc Zemour c'est ce que
j'ai voulu dire dans mon discours c'est
ce que ne disent pas les autres ce qu'il
propose c'est ce que ne feront pas les
autres parce que ceux qui se qui se sont
succédés
depuis 30 ans depuis 40 ans ils ont fait
les mêmes promesses mais les ont pas
tenu je vous voyais à l'instant Philippe
de Villier prendre le temps de saluer
les militants de prendre des des selfies
de signer peut-être des des autographes
que vous disent les gens ils me disent
merci ils disent merci aidez-nous
sauvez-nous merci de nous sauver merci
de nous aider merci de nous comprendre
et donc en fait on est à fond enversé
parce que moi je viens leur dire merci
d'être là et c'est eux qui me disent
merci c'est c'est bouleversant c'est
très touchant et je veux vous dire
surtout moi j'ai eu les larmes aux yeux
à plusieurs reprises en écoutant
Eric c'était magnifique quand il parlait
de la France il y avait la tour eff il y
avait le
mar le maréchal Foch il avait cette
foule cette forêt de sourire de
drapeau c'était vraiment la France le
cœur battant de de la France donc moi je
pense qu'il va se passer quelque chose
vous parlez de l'importance de la mise
en scène on évoquait avec une militante
précédemment cette mise en scène d'Éric
Zemour qui arrive sur scène en marchant
de manière extrêmement solennelle est-ce
que l'objectif c'est de de montrer qu'il
est dans le costume
présidentiel ben c'est de
montrer la présidentialité d'Éric
Zemour et en fait Éric Zemour il est
c'est c'est quelqu'un
qui premièrement dit la
vérité de et la vérité elle est parfois
cruelle et il nomme les choses il nomme
le réel ensuite c'est le seul qui veut
vraiment non pas réformer la France mais
sauver la France qui est aujourd'hui en
pro à un grand remplacement
et un remplacement de civilisation pas
seulement un remplacement de population
et
puis
j'invite les téléspectateurs et lecteurs
du Figaro aller
voir vendredi avec Morandini la colline
du CRAC et là on voit un homme qui ne
recule pas qui ne cè pas qui ne bronche
pas il trace sa route il avance pas de
pas de côté pas de marche
arrière il est là pour montrer aux
Français près du mur de la honte ce que
la France pourrait devenir dans 10 ans
dans 20 ans si on ne fait rien voilà et
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça ça veut
dire
que le courage chez lui n'est pas une
vertu mieux que ça c'est un instinct une
dernière question Philippe deviler il
reste de semaines tout pile avant le
premier tour pour l'instant Éric Zemour
est à peu près à 11 % dans les
intentions de vote qu'est-ce qu' va se
passer maintenant pendant C ces de
semaines jusque jusqu'au vote je pense
qu'on est dans une élection
présidentielle complètement inédite qui
n'a rien à voir avec les précédentes
puisquil y a pas de campagne le
président est
réélu donc ça change tout puisque le
président est réélu donc
il y aura une abstention record et là il
y aura des surprises vous pensez qu'É
Zemour peut aller chercher Marine Le Pen
voir Emmanuel Macron ah je crois que
tout est possible parce que il y a
personne qui mobilise comme ça là il y
a il y a le nombre et il y a aussi
l'intensité c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment
magnifique voilà donc je je pense que il
va se passer quelque chose merci
beaucoup Philippe Deville et soutient
bien connu d'Éric Zemour d'avoir réagi
donc en exclusivité pour Le Figaro à la
fin de ce de ce meeting Philippe de
Vilet vous le voyez derrière moi qui est
à plutôt la côte chez les militants d'éc
Zemour on le voit qui enchaîne les
selfies depuis tout à l'heure et je ne
sais pas si vous si vous l'entendez mais
par exemple aussitôt nous avons terminé
cette interview tout de suite Philippe
de Villet Philippe de Villet son nom qui
est scandé par par les militant voilà
Philippe de Villet qui a d'ailleurs été
ovationné au début de de son de son
intervention à la à la tribune donc un
homme qui a plutôt la côte chez les chez
les militants d'Éric zimour merci
beaucoup Timothé merci pour cette cette
cette réaction et c'est cette interview
de de Philippe
Devillier
Guillaume vous connaissez également
Philippe dev Villier est-ce qu'on a le
Philippe dev Villier com en euh sur sur
ça ou bien est-ce qu'il y a il y a là on
est dans l'authenticité non moi je je
crois vraiment que Philippe dev Villier
là
est parfaitement sincère c'est-à-dire
que il y a bien sûr l'homme politique
qui a été je
dirais donc qui a eu la nécessité pour
défendre le département de la Vendé pour
défendre le puit du fou parfois de de
prendre des position qui n'était pas
nécessairement celle qu'il portait dans
son cœur mais il a toujours défendu ce
qui lui apparaissait comme étant le bien
commun et donc parfois certains
certaines personnes n'ont pas forcément
compris les positions qu'il prenaient
moi effectivement j'ai vu un Philippe
Devillier qui il y a encore 6 mois
était assez abattu par les circonstances
politiques on sait qu'il a été extr
exêmement hostile au
confinement qu'il a je dirais dénoncé je
dirais une politique de surveillance
généralisé et me semble-t-il plutôt à
juste titre mais il était je dirais dans
une position assez comment dire
combative certes mais mais il avait
l'air fatigué pour dire les choses très
très très simplement or j'ai
l'impression que la campagne l'a
métamorphosé qu'il a rajeuni qu'il a un
débit or qui est devenu beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus agile et il me semble que
il est dans une position non pas de se
battre pour lui-même mais de se battre
pour une cause et que de ce point de
vue-là effectivement il est il manifeste
une une vraie une vraie sincérité dans
dans dans les propos dans les propos
qu'il qu'il tient euh le fait que
Timothé l'a dit il y ait eu au cours de
de ce
meeting beaucoup de personnes qui les
ovation
ne me paraît pas très étonnant dans le
sens où il a une position centrale
finalement dans le le dispositif
zemouriste central parce que il a été
avec Jean-Frédéric Poisson l'un des
premiers chef de parti à je dirais
rejoindre Eric Zemour et central d'un
point de vue je dirais sociologique
c'est-à-dire que il représente le MPF
combat pour les valeurs avant le MPF
ensuite représente finalement cette aile
droite de euh de la droite
traditionnelle qui hésitait à basculer
vers le rassemblement national mais qui
en même temps ne supportait plus les
positions de la droite parlementaire et
donc effectivement à ce double titre
Philippe Devillier est euh est comment
dire central dans ce dispositif euh on
va
euh conclure cette cet après-midi de
live que vous nous avez accompagné euh
Guillaume peut-être une dernière
question parce que c'était là aussi au
cœur des des interview que nous avons
que nous avons eu cette internaute nous
dit laamue est quand même
impressionnante sur Éric Zemour
euh il y a un point qui je trouve
frappant dans les interviews qu'on a eu
c'est quand même on a eu des gens
d'origine étrangère et la thématique de
l'assimilation a été extrêmement
présente au cours du discours est-ce
qu'il y a pas également quelque chose un
phénomène un petit peu là euh j'allais
pas dire inédit mais en tout cas à
remarquer d'avoir autant insisté sur non
seulement la dénonciation euh de de
l'immigration mais également à une
alternative autre que le retour des
immigrés dans leur pays d'origine mais
en matière de en matière d'intégration
ou plus exactement en matière
d'assimilation alors je crois que c'est
un thème qui avait été développé
auparavant en particulier par exemp par
Jean-Marie Le Pen mais c'était un thème
qui était inaudible parce que c'était le
grand blond breton qui exigeait que les
immigrés et bien deviennent français et
donc finalement se convertissent à
l'identité française dans la mesure où
Éric Zemour et lui-même et bien d'une
certaine manière ethniquement
culturellement
d'origine étrangère je mets tout ça
entre guillemets n'est-ce pas et bien il
est bien évident que toute une partie de
Français eux-mêmes d'origine immigrés et
qui ont fait l'effort de l'assimilation
parce que il y en a un très grand nombre
qui l'ont fait il y en a toute une
partie qui l'ont refusé et qui Contin
continuent à le refuser mais il y en a
toute une partie qui en revanche l'ont
fait ce processus d'assimilation et bien
dans le fond ils sont rassurés par le
fait que et bien ils peuvent assumer le
fait qu'ils aient fait le choix de la
France et donc de ce point de vue-là oui
Éric Zémour décloisonne sans doute plus
que ne l'avait fait auparavant d'autres
personnes qui pouvaient défendre les
mêmes positions sur la question de
l'immigration euh pour terminer euh
Guillaume euh alors on a encore quelques
dernières images là qui nous reviennent
du Trocadero on va les prendre dès que
la la caméra de Raphaël va va un petit
peu dépasser le cadre de la barrière euh
une dernière question pour terminer euh
d'abord euh vous parlez de de le le
discours d'éc Zemour même s'il
abordait d'autres thèmes est quand même
essentiellement axé
sur la crainte de la fin de la France
est-ce que cette
thématique est-ce qu'il n'est pas en
décalage par rapport aux thématiques
central de cette campagne présidentielle
alors il est en décalage dans la mesure
où il a voulu se focaliser sur un seul
thème pour autant ce thème-là est
parfaitement inscrit dans la
préoccupation des Français c'est-à-dire
que le thème de la préférence trans
naationale le thème je dirais de
effectivement de l'immigration choisie
ou disons de la comment dire de de de de
de de la limitation de l'immigration ce
sont des sujets sur lesquels auxquels
les Français s'intéressent mais il a
considéré et c'est peut-être là une de
ces erreurs stratégiques qu'il fallait
tout focaliser sur un thème et en
négliger d'autre c'est ce que je vous
disais à propos tout à l'heure de la
comparaison avec la campagne de Trump où
Trump a accepté l'idée qu'il pouvait
livé sur tout un ensemble de sujets et
pas sur un seul des sujets il a
considéré ERC Zemour que le thème de
l'immigration et de l'identité parce
qu'il rassemblait une très grande
majorité de Français au moins 75 % des
Français qui sont finalement sur les
positions qu'il tient même s'il n'adhère
pas forcément exactement à toutes de ses
formulations et bien que ça ça lui
permettrait de rassembler de rassembler
un électorat le problème c'est que
d'abord il est concurrence
par d'autres personnes qui peuvent tenir
évidemment le même type de discours par
exemple Marine Le Pen évidemment et qui
a une marque Le Pen Ren même si c'est
plus le Front national mais qui a quand
même une marque qui est beaucoup plus
ancienne que lui et donc il y a commême
un effet d'inertie qui fait qu'il y a
toute une partie de l'électorat qui va
continuer à voter même si l'offre de
Zemour est nouvelle et et peut en
attirer en attirer certains et puis et
puis il y a incontestablement le fait
que il apparaît encore peut-être à tort
mais comme étant monothématique or on
sait très bien que dans une campagne
électorale pour la présidentielle il est
délicat effectivement de n'apparaître
que comme une organisation
monothématique regardez par exemple pour
les écologistes il n'arrive pas à percer
à la présidentielle Guillaume Pelletier
est avec Timothé d'EM on va leur laisser
la parole on y revient juste après bien
merci d'être avec nous je vois que vous
enchaînez les les selfies que vous
disent les militants il y a une ferveur
incroyable moi ça fait 20 ans que je
suis engagé j'en ai vu des meetings et
des réunions y compris ici autant de
monde autant de ferveur autant autant de
détermination avec des profil qui
viennent de partout des gens qui ont
voté Chirac Sarkozy Le Pen Villier qui
se rassemblent enfin d'abord sur la même
place mais pour un même objectif avec
Eric Zemour ça c'est inédit et c'est
extraordinaire qu'est-ce qui vous fait
dire qu'erc Zemour peut faire mentir les
sondages et aller chercher cette
qualification pour le second tour dans 2
semaines toute l'expérience que j'ai des
campagnes présidentielles et en
particulier de celle-ci dont chacun
s'accorde à dire que en raison de la
crise sanitaire de la guerre en ucraine
les sondeurs sont perdus que les
Français regardent et vont se décider
dans la dernière ligne droite et ben
dans la dernière ligne droite qui a
rassemblé le plus de monde qui a le
discours le plus clair sur l'immigration
qui n'est pas un politicien comme les
autres qui a envie de rassembler le
l'ensemble de la droite c'est éc Zemmour
donc j'ai pas de doute qu'il créera la
surprise le 10 avril depuis le début de
la guerre en Ukraine on voit qu'éc
Zemour a un reculé dans les dans les
sondages il a certaines de ces anciennes
déclarations qui font un peu de tâche
qui sont ressorties qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez vous savez si on ressortait
euh sur la question de Poutine vous
m'interrogez Jacques chirar a remis la
liégion d'honneur avvenir Poutine
Nicolas Sarkozi à juste titre est venu
défendre les intérêts de la France de
l'Europe et de la paix sur la crise
géorgienne avec Vladimir Poutine
Emmanuel Macron est en contact régulier
et il a raison avec Vladimir Poutine
donc j'ai envie de dire que les
caricatur on les laisse de côté il y en
a qu'un qui aime la France il y en a un
qui n'est pas un politicien il y en a
qu'un qui va rassemblé toute la droite
et toutes les droites et c'est
extraordinaire c'est é zour donc que
chacun prenne conscience que pour battre
Macron il y a qu'un vote utile efficace
et vital c'est le votour merci beaucoup
Guillaume ptier prier viceprésident de
reconquête qui réagit donc pour Figaro
live à la fin de ce discours d'Emmanuel
Macron Vincent je vous redonne la parole
merci beaucoup Timothé et on va
justement conclure sur cette interview
de de Guillaume
Peltier peut-être une une réaction à ce
que vous avez entendu de du premier
vice-président de reconquête ah il est
certain qu'évidemment là Guillaume
Peltier joue son rôle d'essayer de de
rassembler moi je je suis évidemment
plus je suis extérieur je dirais à la à
la campagne d'éc Zémour et de et de
reconquête et pour l'heure encore une
fois il peut y avoir des surprises mais
pour l'heure on va avoir au soir du
premier tour deux organisations
concurrentes sur je dirais un même
espace politique on aura la fois une
droite nationale ou une droite radicale
qui sera la première force politique en
additionnant tous les différents
candidats mais qui est divisé et on ne
pouvait on ne peut envisager que
reconquête ne devienne ce qu'ils veulent
c'est-à-dire l'Union des droites ou
l'unité de la droite ce qui me paraît
plus judicieux d'ailleurs de parle de
d'utiliser comme expression plutôt qu'un
a des droites mais pasce qu'on c'est pas
le sujet ici qu'ils ne peuvent envisager
de le faire ou qu'il ne pourraient
envisager véritablement de le faire que
s'ils arrivaient à surpasser Marine Le
Pen et à se subsit tué entièrement à
elle ça ne sera pas le cas et donc ça
veut dire que l'élection présidentielle
de 2022 c'est une première étape dans la
recomposition de la vie politique après
l'émergence d'Emmanuel Macron qui a été
évidemment un événement extrêmement
important puisqu'il a institutionnaliser
la
cohabitation le rassemblement de la
droite et de la gauche et de la gauche
modérée le vrai problème évidemment pour
toutes les forces politiques c'est
l'abstention et Philippe dev Villier l'a
dit tout à l'heure je crois qu'il a
parfaitement raison c'est est-ce que on
ne laisse pas entièrement partir à la
dérive toute une partie de l'électorat
qui et bien ne voit plus aucun espoir ça
c'est évidemment quelque chose de très
grave euh parce que il y a des
conditions de vie dans l'insécurité
physique matérielle économique
culturelle une insécurité qui fait que
certains Français baissent entièrement
les bras ça c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement grave et même de nouvelles
forces politiques comme reconquête
n'arrivve semble pas je dirais à les
mobiliser est-ce qu'il peut y avoir une
surprise justement en terme de
participation je vous pose la question
différemment est-ce que on aura un
indicateur assez fort le soir du premier
tour à partir de de 17h avec le chiffre
de l'abstention est-ce que ce sera un
indicateur du résultat final
ah oui il est vraisemblable que si la
participation est plus grande qu'elle
n'est prévue normalement cela
signifierait que les force contestatrice
Mélenchon Le Pen Zemmour je les donne
dans cet ordre làà mais pas pour donner
une hiérarchie sont susceptibles
d'engranger un plus grand nombre un plus
grand nombre de voix et donc de faire un
pourcentage plus élevé que ce qui est
normalement que ce qui est normalement
prévu je vous signale que on a eu une
surprise lors des européennes de 2019 on
pensait qu'il y aurait une très forte
abstention puisque depuis 1979
l'abstention n'avait cessé de progr lors
de ces élections là et que en 2019 il y
a eu une plus forte participation que
lors de l'élection précédente de 2014
une plus oui une plus forte
participation que lorsque que que que
lors d'élection présidente de 2014 donc
euh effectivement on peut envisager
c'est pas le sens que cela prend pour
l'instant mais encore une fois on verra
bien on verra bien je dirais ce que ce
que seront les résultats la
participation quel que soit le vote je
crois que c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel parce que c'est un sentiment
d'intégration un électeur qui va voter
même s'il vote blanc même s'il vote nul
même s'il vote pour quelque parti que ce
soit ça veut dire qu'il a encore le
sentiment d'appartenir au corps social
quelqu'un qui ne va pas voter c'est
quelqu'un qui finalement se considère
comme étant abandonné par la société
dans laquelle il vit c'est quand même
profondément triste s'il y avait un mot
pour résumer cet après-midi pour résumer
le le le ce discours d'Éric Zemour il
essaye il a réussi incontestablement une
mobilisation parce que il est la
nouveauté de la campagne de 2022 il a
réussi à construire une force militante
extrêmement importante mais une ambigué
reste c'est-à-dire que il fait un appel
à l'électorat
LR qu'il a déjà en grande partie capté
alors qu'il n'arrive pas à euh s'emparer
des positions populaires ou populistes
de Marine Le Pen et donc par conséquent
effectivement on peut s'interroger sur
l'objectif je dirais de d'Erc Zemour
enfin en tout cas sur la capacité d'Éric
Zemour à effectivement reprendre des
voix à Marine Le Pen et à progresser et
en particulier dans ces catégories
populaires merci beaucoup Guillaume
Bernard de nous avoir commenté analysé
et débriefer ce meeting merci beaucoup à
vous d'avoir été nombreux vous avez été
extrêmement nombreux en particulier
notamment sur la page Youtube du Figaro
et vous avez été nombreux également bien
sûr à nous suivre sur le site du Figaro
vous l'avez sans doute remarqué si vous
êtes sur le site du Figaro le meeting de
Valéri pcrè a commencé depuis déjà une
dizaine de minutes le meeting
particulier par zoom nous serons
également en direct de son prochain
meeting la semaine prochaine également
en direct de l'Arena à Nanterre pour le
meeting d'Emmanuel Macron ce sont nos
premiers prochains grands rendez-vous
présidentiel et grand rendez-vous de
meeting bien évidemment nous serons en
direct le soir du premier tour pour une
soirée spéciale qui commencera dès 19h
sur Figaro live et bien sûr toute la
journée en direct sur le site du Figaro
on se retrouve également sur Figaro live
demain prochain rendez-vous donc le buzz
à partir de midi et demain soir point de
vue 18h également audition publique à
19h30 l'émission avec la Chaîne
Parlementaire rpuique Sénat avec qui
nous recevrons le président du Conseil
européen Charles Michel merci beaucoup
de nous avoir suivi merci de votre
fidélité à Figaro live et vous restez
avec nous puisque sur le Figaro il y a
d'autres vidéos et d'autres
infos